mon chaton sera ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de ses nains
360 voici les titres ap le sénat a
transmis le cas les cas de trois
collaborateurs de l'elysée à la justice
le bureau du sénat a pris cette décision
à l'unanimité comme alexandre bennane à
eybens ancrage ils sont soupçonnés
d'avoir menti sous serment à une
commission denquête les explications à
suivre et ce vote a été perçu comme un
procès politique du sénat contre
l'elysée vous entendrez dans un instant
la réaction de benjamin griveaux
porte-parole du gouvernement ainsi que
le président yvon voix centristes au
sénat hervé marseille pour qui le bureau
est allé trop loin
la séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est à suivre en direct et
en exclusivité sur notre antenne dans un
instant et puis je vous rappelle que
vous pouvez réagir sur twitter à cette
édition avec le hashtag sénat 360 pour
m'accompagner à cet après-midi pour
toutes à l'érection dessinateur salle
des concurrents on se retrouvera à tam
tran huy et alexandre poussard en direct
de l'hémicycle dans notre métier plex
dans un instant
et justement emprunte au dessus de la
direction de la salle des conférences
pour une première réaction à cette
décision du bureau du sénat qui a
tranché la haute assemblée a fait le
choix de transmettre à la justice je
lisais les cas d'alexandre le bénin est
dedans sans grade mais surtout soit des
proches collaborateurs de l'elysée est
un homme vous êtes avec et bien jean
marc gabouty membres du bureau sénateurs
rdse
oui effectivement jean marc gabouty
comment c'est passé tout simplement le
bureau du sénat ce matin finalement la
majorité assez a été assez large pour
transmettre les cas de patrick strzoda
alexis kohler et du général lavergne à
la justice comment ça s'est passé
alors un petit rectificatif seul le nom
de patrick thomas apparaît oui ensuite
tous les autres témoignages sont
transmis à la justice donc c'est
uniquement patrick strzoda effet tous
les cas il ya ces suspicions de faux
témoins il ya eu une discussion au sein
du bureau chacun pu faire valoir ses
arguments je pense que les positions
étaient quand même assez arrêté avant
d'entrer en séance c'est peut-être
regrettable donc voilà ensuite la
décision le bureau est souverain s'ils
n'empêchent pas aux uns et aux autres
d'avoir nos propres positions et vous
étiez vous personnellement opposé vous
aviez même dénoncé auparavant un rapport
à charge
est ce que pour vous à cette commission
des requêtes avait des visées politiques
c'est ce que l'on entend aujourd'hui de
la part est bien de la majorité
présidentielle alors moi je veux jouer
mais que les décisions soient prises sur
la base d'une argumentation solide est
fondée je trouve que l'argumentation et
les conclusions reposent sur des
interprétations sur des approximations
voire sur des sur des inexactitudes
les trois hauts fonctionnaires on va
savoir patrick strzoda pour voler trois
pour les 3 pour l'ensemble parce que il
est où on a essayé de les mettre en
contradiction les uns avec les autres de
dire qu' il avait dit la même chose oui
mais il y en a un qui avait cité la note
de service du 5 juillet 2010 est donc on
est un peu dans la finasserie alors dans
le juridique vous dira le président
larcher valérie létard ils sont basés
effectivement sur le juridique pour
faire une différenciation entre patrick
strzoda et les deux autres
collaborateurs
certains à droite disent qu'il ya eu des
pressions sur des membres du bureau
est-ce que vous pour votre part vous
avez été appelé est ce qu'on vous a
promis des choses pour votre vote c'est
ce qu'insinue certains non non non non
non non non non il y en a qui fantasment
moi je j'ai cette liberté la démarche
que j'ai faite d'adresser un courrier à
valérie létard et au président il y à il
ya une dizaine de jours et est une
démarche totalement spontanée et
volontaire et je n'ai eu absolument
aucune
aucune pression j'ai pas l'habitude vous
savez j'ai eu jamais eu des pressions
lorsque j'avais lutté contre la
déchéance de nationalité mais cette fois
ci j'en ai pas eu à les relations entre
l'exécutif et le sénat étaient déjà
assez mauvaise est ce que pour vous le
dialogue va être rompu et
particulièrement dans le contexte des
négociations sur la révision
constitutionnelle bien sûr du coude et
moi j'avais le sentiment que les
relations étaient en train un peu de
s'améliorer parce que présent la
république a compris que les besoins des
territoires et des élus locaux dont il a
fait un pas dans leur direction
notamment à l'occasion du grand débat et
qu'on pouvait avoir ce rapprochement sur
sur plusieurs textes même s'il doit y
avoir des désaccords le sénat a été et
est indépendant le groupe majoritaire se
situe plutôt dans dans l'opposition je
crois que là c'est un coup de frein
effectivement au climat de confiance qui
était en train de se rétablir entre
entre le sénat l'exécutif et je le
regrette parce que je pense que ce n'est
pas bon pour c'est pas bon pour le
gouvernement c'est vrai c'est pas bon
pour le sénat non plus bien merci
beaucoup jean marc gabouty pour votre
réaction
merci beaucoup première du vote numéro
fait le choix de transmettre mais
surtout ceux des proches collaborateurs
patronat générale à berne
explication jonathan les prix s l'issue
du vote était incertaine les sénateurs
ont décidé de transmettre à la justice
les cas des trois hauts responsables de
la présidence
alexis colère secrétaire général de
l'elysée le général lionel lavergne chef
du gspr et patrick strzoda directeur de
cabinet des manuels macron la commission
d' enquête parlementaire leur reprochait
d'avoir retenu une part significative de
la vérité lors des auditions
certains membres du bureau salue une
décision cohérente
c'était un rendez vous à ne pas manquer
personne n'aurait compris que le bureau
des juges le travail remarquable de la
commission d' enquête qui a été menée
par philippe braun chercheur et mériel
jourdain avec la plus grande rigueur
sans jamais aucun dérapage la commission
d'enquêté rester dans son couloir tout
du long
en ne mélangeons pas les genres et en
respectant scrupuleusement la séparation
du pouvoir qui est essentielle dans
cette république est cette démocratie
à l'unanimité les sénateurs ont voté la
transmission des cas d'alexandre benalla
et vincent kraz mais sur les 26 membres
du bureau
six ont voté contre la transmission du
castro da à la justice et 7 contre celle
d'alexis colère et lionel lavergne
majoritairement des centristes pour
qu'ils le sénat est allé trop loin
un certain nombre de mise en
responsabilité et est superfétatoire
il ya eu un travail important qui était
fait par cette commission denquête au
monde a reconnu c'était l'honneur du
sénat que de contrôler l'exécutif comme
l'a fait le sénat et la commission
denquête il ya eu une chose peut-être
qui est allé un peu trop loin
à mes yeux et qui était pas
nécessairement justifié c'est la mise en
cause d'un certain nombre de
responsables au plus haut niveau de
l'état
de son côté le parti présidentiel accuse
le coup le président du groupe lrm au
sénat dénonce un procès politique je
considère aujourd'hui que
sans doute c'est la part du sénat une
volonté manifeste de mettre à mal
l'exécutif est un peu haut niveau et que
c'est une manoeuvre additionnelle qui se
pensent de tence et éthiques les
sénateurs rappellent toutefois que la
décision du bureau ne vaut pas
condamnation et qu'elle ne saurait se
substituer au travail de la justice
les collaborateurs ont fait débat
pourquoi leur quartier finalement été
transmis à la justice la réponse de
content car selon le rapport final de la
commission denquête les trois hauts
responsables à l'elysée sont soupçonnés
je cite d'avoir retenu une part
significative de la vérité alexis colère
le secrétaire général de l'elysée le
général lavergne chef de la sécurité du
président de la république et patrick
strzoda le directeur de cabinet des
manuels macron leur témoignage a
intrigué les sénateurs au mois de
juillet il avait été interrogé notamment
sur la fonction d'alexandre benhadda à
l'elysée et voici leurs réponses
alexandre benalla était chargé de
mission auprès de la chefferie de
cabinet c'est à dire auprès de l'entité
qui au sein du cabinet présente à un
public est chargée d'organiser son
agenda ses déplacements une version
répété par patrick strzoda et le général
lavergne selon eux alexandre benalla
n'avait que trois missions à l'elysée la
gestion des déplacements publics celle
des déplacements privés et
l'organisation de la cérémonie du 14
juillet une version qui va se révéler
problématique au mois de septembre alors
que nous avions demandé la fiche de
poste monsieur benalla et que nous
étions sur le point d'obtenir la
présidence de la république a reconnu et
s'est inscrit dans la fiche de poste que
monsieur benalla exerçaient une fonction
de coordination des services de sécurité
la note de service évoqué est un
document daté du mois de juillet 2010
est où figure bien la mission d'
alexandre ménard auprès des services de
sécurité
les sénateurs ont ainsi recensé sept
pages d'un incohérences dans les
témoignages de ces hauts responsables
des éléments qui vont désormais être
transmis au parquet dans ce nouveau
volet judiciaire de l'affairé benalla
et on ouvre le débat dont sénat 360 avec
mes invités sur ce plateau françoise
gatel bonjour bienvenue à vous vous êtes
sénatrice centriste d'ille-et-vilaine
également sur ce plateau eric bouquet
bonjour vous êtes sénateur communiste du
nord
j'accueille également françois
grosdidier merci des trains ic nos
sénateurs l ère de la moselle et puis
samuel le goff et également sur ce
plateau journée ce parlementaire pour le
site contexte première question pour
vous françoise gatel est ce que le sénat
s'est uniquement basée sur le droit pour
prendre sa décision on a tout de suite
vu les différentes critiquant notamment
du parti aux présidentielles qui voit un
procès politique de la part du sénat
contre l'exécutif
je pense que quelle que soit la décision
on aurait eu et on a une
instrumentalisation de divers ordres sur
cette décision moi je veux saluer tout
d'abord le travail de la commission dont
universellement n'a reconnu la grande
rigueur la qualité ensuite ce matin au
bureau il y a une qualité d'expression
très respectueuse et le président
larcher a bien resituer les choses en
disant nous n'étions pas des juges
nous étions amenés à exercer notre
mission en notre âme et conscience si je
puis dire et valérie létard afin
excellent rapport ensuite il appartient
à chacun d'entre nous est vraiment les
débats ont été assez remarquable de
d'exprimer les déductions qu'ils font de
ce que sont nos obligations et de ce que
nous avons lu et compris les centristes
ont voté contre justement à tort j'ai
fait ma - voilà alors votre expression
on va dire que votre expression renvoie
la transition en même temps moi je veux
d'illégal et réclame en vain que moi je
n'ai pas eu de pression et que sur la
décision que j'avais à prendre depuis
hier j'essayais d'être dans l'esprit
d'un jury d'assises en me forget en mon
intime conviction donc je me suis fait
une grille d'analysé de critères
déterminants volontairement mensonges et
de temps et j'ai coché des cases ou pas
pour chacun des personnages voilà d'où
la déduction que j'en ai tiré et le vote
qui a été le mien mais je dis n'y a pas
eu de coalition centriste et de postures
centre et des centristes
très reconnus pour leur liberté de vote
et leur capacité à exprimer un choix
individuel il en est ainsi à une moc est
il en allait de la crédibilité de la
commission denquête ce matin c'était
aussi un des enjeux du val numéro oui et
de la crédibilité du sénat y compris en
tant que assemblée souveraine libre et
indépendante dans cette république avec
la place et le rôle qui est le sien
je veux confirmer les propos de ma
collègue françoise gatel sur la tenue
des débats ce matin effectivement bureau
plus de deux heures de discussions où
chacun s'est exprimé 25 interventions
chacun avec sa sensibilité ses arguments
exprimant des doutes et interrogations
parfois légitime tout le monde s'écoute
et je pense que le sénat le bureau du
sénat a pris la bonne décision parce que
je personne n'aurait compris à l'interné
et à l'externe que le sénat puisse des
juges et des travaux la commission
denquête reconnu unanimement pour leur
rigueur et leur sérieux au contraire est
allé un peu trop loin ça son jeu je
comprends pas du tout la position du
président du groupe centriste mais je
comprends cette du compas marche qui est
dans un exercice obligé non en fait le
sénat ne pouvais pas en faire moins on
n'a pas demandé aux responsables de
l'elysée de mentir devant la commission
d'enquêté en direct devant des millions
de français
s'il avait simplement admis que monsieur
benalla arrivant avec le staff de
campagne et bien s'occuper de sécurité
et que ça se soit c'est interférer avec
les services publics de sécurité et que
c'était recadrer même la sphère de
l'estac la sphère judiciaire ne
concernait pas on se serait arrêté à ça
eh bien nous ont rendu notre apport donc
ce n'était pas normal et en préconisant
que ce soit bien les aides publiques de
sécurité qui gère la protection d'un
président république et ça s'arrêtait là
ils nous ont expliqué tout le contraire
que monsieur benalla s'occuper de tout
sauf de sécurité fias se rendent compte
qu'ils avaient une autorisation de port
d'armes pour assurer des missions de
sécurité que l'ancien ministre gérard
collomb ministre d'intérieur nous disent
qu'ils connaissent à peine monsieur
vénéra qu'il l'avait croisé qui le
prenait pour un policier quoi deux font
de telles invraisemblances on ne pouvait
pas se contenter de saisir la justice du
cas des lampistes benalla écrase et puis
de les misérables et de protéger les
puissants
donc on aurait perdu toute crédibilité
je rappelle qu'on a saisi la juge
6 pour le cas d'un professeur de
médecine qui avait menti devant la
commission d' enquête sur la sécurité de
m
c'était pas un procès politique donc il
n'y a rien de politique au sens partisan
simplement nous nous assurons notre rôle
notre mission de contrôle et nous ne
pouvons pas le faire si on laisse mentir
devant une commission d enquête
parlementaire
merci je voudrais réagir aux propos de
mon collègue il ne s'agissait pas ce
matin je le rappelle soyons très
factuelle précis et rigoureux comme nous
l'avons été soit 1 il ne s'agissait pas
de valider ou d'approuver le rapport le
rapport il existe personne ne l'a
contesté maintenant le bureau a été
amené à prendre des décisions au vu de
sa capacité à agir et qu'ensuite il ya
une jurisprudence mon cher collègue qui
remonte même à 2847 qui montre que le
sénat et d'autres institutions dans des
situations parfois parallèle ses
institutions et le sénat ont pris des
positions durant et moi je ne peux pas
laisser dire qu'il aura d'une part des
lampistes enfin je regrette mais
monsieur benalla est tout sauf un
lampiste enfin il me semble que il est
le personnage central de cette affaire
qui s'est opérée dans un cadre où il
n'ya pas de pare feu ce que l'on en fait
je ne vous ai rien trahir ma chère
collègue du secret si votre position je
vous mettais pas encodeur c'est le
président du groupe centriste et non pas
tous les centristes puisqu'ils sont tous
indépendants les uns des autres
non mais je dis simplement que ils ont
menti les uns et des autres et qu'on ne
peut pas dire monsieur crise monsieur
benalla répondront devant l'ajis et les
autres parce qu'ils sont plus haut gradé
dans les institutions la république
doivent y échapper voilà ce que je dis
simplement que le sénat justement a
voulu cibler l'exécutif en l'occurrence
l'elysée à travers ce bas de ce matin le
numéro du sénat le vote du bureau du
sénat était un peu contraint quand même
puisque dès la conférence de presse de
présentation
les noms de benalla et de vincent 15 ans
avait été clairement annoncé comme ayant
menti
le vrai enjeu ce matin c'était
effectivement est ce que les faits qui
sont reprochés aux trois collaborateurs
du président de la république sont
suffisants pour justifier une
transmission puisque il ya aussi un
risque que le procès
classée sans suite et dans ce cas là
c'est un peu le retour de boomerang au
sénat donc la jurisprudence existe mais
elle est récente
donc il ne faudrait pas qu'à la deuxième
utilisation les sénateurs se retrouve
pris à revers et il ya aussi bien sûr
l'enjeu politique on arrive à la fin du
grand débat on sait qu'un certain nombre
de textes de loi vont arriver qu'il va
falloir trouver des compromis et c'est
un petit peu compliqué pour le président
du sénat il est responsable du sida de
se retrouver à la table de négociation à
l'elysée après avoir créé une tension en
mettant en cause puisque quelque part à
l'elysée c'est ressenti comme une
agression
ce qui est logique justement c'est une
situation embarrassante pour les chaînes
de l'état eric bocquet on le voit à la
fois patrick strzoda directeur de
cabinet mme emmanuelle macron alexis
colère secrétaire général de l'elysée et
le général lionel lavergne qui dirige le
groupe de sécurité
la présidence de la république ça va
fragiliser emmanuel macron c'est pas une
décision anodine d'ailleurs tout le
monde l'a mesuré ce matin des membres du
bureau dans l'intervention le rappeler
c'est une décision lourde de conséquence
effectivement mais ça n'est pas non plus
une condamnation
c'est une saisine de la justice la
commission denquête encore une fois à
mener un travail absolument remarquable
irréprochable tous les plans mais elle a
ses limites de ses prérogatives au-delà
c'est la justice qui seul peut trancher
avec ses moyens d'investigation son
indépendance y compris en terme de
pouvoir et donc à moins donné il faut la
saisir en tout en toute liberté
attendez c'est pas si terrible on ne se
permet pas de juger la place des juges
on ouvre simplement la possibilité aux
magistrats de juger n'est pas qu'ils
vont tous être condamnées ou poursuivies
simplement on a relevé les
contradictions et donc les mensonges au
moment où ça a été dit puisque d'autres
choses ont été dites ensuite autrement
par les mêmes souvent et est bien est ce
que c'est un mensonge veut pas
caractérisés pénalement
c'est ce sera au parquet de le faire
éventuellement de saisir le juge du fond
donc pour nommer mais si nous ne le
faisions pas à en ayant souligné les
contradictions on nous reprocherait avec
raison et bien de vouloir épargner ceux
qui sont au sommet de la hiérarchie va
payer que ceux qui étaient tombés
française gatin oui mais moi je voudrais
dire que ce matin comme l'a rappelé mon
collègue nous avons été du très grande
rigueur et mon cher collègue le travail
que nous avions amené n'était pas
celui de la commission et moi je
soutiens totalement et je l' ai bien dit
la démarche de la commission la façon
dont le travail était conduite nous nous
devions nous prononcer en fonction d'un
article 6 de l'ordonance de novembre 58
qui détermine ce qu'est un faux
témoignage est dedans il ya un élément
extrêmement important qui explique en
tout cas ma position par rapport au
cadre de monsieur straub à qui la nature
déterminante du mensonge et moi j'ai en
déductions en quelque sorte estimé que
ce que monsieur straubing n'avait pas
dit n'avait pas empêché de faire éclater
la vérité et que donc qu'il n'y avait
pas ce caractère déterminant donc moi je
ne veux pas laisser n'a pas menti par
omission de nommer moi jamais seul jeu
mairie m je ne peux pas laisser dire
comme moi en tout cas enfin que moi qui
ai pris cette décision j'aurais balayé
d'un revers de main ce qu'a fait la
commission je l'aurais déjuger et que je
serai en quelque sorte irresponsable
parce que j'aurai décrété que monsieur
benalla serait en fait c'est juste une
présentation chers collègues tout le
respect l'amitié que j'ai pour vous que
je n'aime pas plus qu'une
instrumentalisation inversée à
l'encontre du sénat il n'y en a aucune
alors monsieur monsieur trop d'à comme
monsieur colère ont bien dit que
monsieur benalla s'occuper tout sauf de
sécurité avant que nous ayons les
preuves contraires et après ça nous
avons des explications changeante au fur
et à mesure du déroulement de la
commission denquête alors si c'est pas
une vie un mensonge c'est une
contre-vérité mais c'est c'est plus
qu'un mensonge par omission
éric haeuw bloqué ce matin comment s'est
passée justement le 20 ans on sait qu'il
ya des extraits vidéo quand ils y ont
été diffusés aux membres du bureau c'est
ça oui nous avons eu l'occasion de re
visionner une courte intervention une ex
un extrait d'intervention de ce strzoda
devant la commission d' enquête sur les
émissions monsieur benalla bon
honnêtement percement j'ai pas très bien
compris ce que ça venait faire dans le
débat va c'était un élément de la
réflexion il n'était pas mon avis
déterminant mais voilà on a eu
effectivement ce moment là aussi parmi
les changes
le pouvoir en lui même ne sera pas
déstabilisé par ce vote du sénat a été
vécue enfin comme une déclaration de
guerre aussi de la haute assemblée
vis-à-vis du gouvernement
alors je pense qu'on en est pas encore à
la mise en examen puisque déjà dense et
déjà quand on relit le communiqué du
bureau
il n'y a que le nom de monsieur strzoda
qui est cité comme transmis au procureur
ensuite on lui amène également on
signale que d'autres auraient pu mais il
n'y a qu'un nom qui est donné mais canal
excès colère voilà voilà ensuite il faut
que le procureur lance et poursuite il
peut très bien décider d'effectivement
de poursuivre monsieur benallal crasse
et de classer sans suite pour monsieur
sont là donc on n'en est pas encore à ce
stade de la de l'ennui pour l'elysée en
sachant quand même que monsieur strzoda
et déjà en retraite de préfet et que vu
le nombre de départs de collaborateurs à
l'elysée puisque un mouvement naturel
c'est au bout d'un moment ils partent
monsieur strzoda peut se retrouver pris
également dans un grand renouvellement
de l'élite je pense que l'elysée n'ait
l'excès colère saura choueir saura gérer
ce genre de choses non pour l'instant
c'est plus effectivement la tension
entre le sénat et la présidence de la
république qui peut se révéler gênant
parce que là le sénat montre un peu les
cro - qui ne se laisse pas faire et que
ben les négociations risquent de pas
être facile dans les mois qui viennent
vous nous faites la transition puisque
cette décision est bien la relance est
certainement les tensions existantes
entre la haute assemblée l'exécutif qui
avait peu goûté d'ailleurs les
recommandations de la commission d'
enquête sur l'organisation interne de
l'elysée marie briot ça y est du côté de
l'exécutif paix de la majorité on lâche
les coûts sur twitter la porte parole
dans marche n'hésite pas à parler de
détournement des institutions de la part
du sénat et d'un procès politique
l'exécutif voit rouge suite à la
décision de la haute assemblée de
transmettre à la justice les k23 proche
des manuels macron point d'orgue de la
sphère benalla qui dure depuis des mois
en séance les passes d'armes sont
nombreuses les rappels à l'ordre aux 6m
de monsieur les mini se rappelle que je
vais suspendre la séance mais je
rappelle à tous que c'est moi qui
préside la séance et moi sommes les
désaccords se succèdent au fil des mois
sur les territoires et leurs
représentations tout d'abord sur la
réforme des institutions également nous
devons donc nous employer à ce que le
sénat représentant les collectivités
territoriales de la république
continuez incarnée par sa composition
l'ensemble des territoires de notre pays
au prétexte de la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires on ne doit pas condamner
au quasi silence certains territoires de
notre pays au prétexte que leur
démographie serait plus faible des
conflits qui s'affichent désormais au
grand jour
gérard larcher ironisant même sur le
bilan du président c'est vrai que
l'année 2019 ne commence pas su sous les
meilleurs auspices pour notre pays donc
peu parce que jouir l'état de la france
on est au fond le constat d'échec de ces
18 mois de présidence qui devait voir
l'avènement d'un monde nouveau s'ouvre
devant nous conquérant et ambitieux
aujourd'hui nul doute que l'ancien monde
savoure sa revanche et en doses plus que
jamais le rôle de contre-pouvoir on ça
se gâte l on disait ça ne sera pas sans
conséquences sur les relations déjà
tendues entre le sénat et l'exécutif et
notamment à la proche de la révision
constitutionnelle
bon voilà c'est fait partie du paysage
maintenant moi je pense que madame
aurore bergé elle aurait dû revoir ses
filles charmantes de de déclarer ce
genre de propos voilà c'est trop
caricatural pour être vrai je pense
qu'on a du mal à faire accepter n'ont
subi que le sénat est tout à fait
indépendant qu'il est capable d'affirmer
et des choses de décider en toute
lucidité et que cela peut contrarier il
faut sic nous on accepte mais si le
sénat avait procédé d'une quelconque
façon
les critiques ont été les mêmes de toute
façon et qu'on peut instrumentaliser les
choses mais j'ai dit là la sphère
benalla il y aurait plus il y aurait pu
ne pas en avoir c'est dire si en mai la
présidence de la république avec décidé
que monsieur benalla avait un
comportement qui était juste
inacceptables dans un univers où il doit
y avoir des pare feux et de la sécurité
je suis dit on ne serait pas là
aujourd'hui à parler de tout ça
maintenant nous sommes là moi j'avoue
alors sans doute suis-je naïve ou que
c'est mais que je pense que ce pays il
est suffisamment malade pour qu'on ne
s'amuse pas à goce d'une manière ultra
instrumentalisé sur cette décision que
le sénat a pris d'une manière assez
remarquable encore une fois moi je veux
saluer la qualité du débat le respecte
et nous
comme dans une démocratie sans doute
peut-on désormais pour négocier dans la
révision constitutionnelle ou est-ce
qu'il ne risque pas de faire les frais
justement de cette décision
ce sens ce serait attendait ce serait
thème de quoi on souffre d'une crise la
démocratie représentative pourquoi parce
que la démocratie parlementaire a jamais
très bien fonctionné en tout cas le
sénat est indépendant fait ce rôle d'un
parlement dans une démocratie
parlementaire
alors que l'assemblée nationale depuis
longtemps c'est pas simplement se
vernement c et bodio j'ai fait trois
mandats je sais ce que c'est donc on est
une démocratie locale qui est
complètement corsetée une démocratie
sociale qui a jamais bien fonctionné
lors il faudrait simplement que le
gouvernement ne réagisse pas en criant
au coup d'état parce qu'ils sont
toujours dans l'idée d'une forme de de
césarisme technocratique et qu'ils
acceptent le fonctionnement de la
démocratie parlementaire et dans les
mots crise parlementaire il ya un débat
avec le parlement et le parlement une
mission de contrôle que l'exécutif doit
accepter sans crier à la confusion des
pouvoirs et ça ira bien mieux pour le
pays
et on aura démontré que quand même quel
que soit mécontentement et bien les
institutions de la république
fonctionnent dans le pays et c'est à
l'honneur du sénat soit que chez makro
on prend tout à coup connaissance de
l'état du pays
moi je suis à cette image soit son
élection avec la pyramide de pei est
derrière lui
monsieur macron croyait on a un pouvoir
vertical descendants ils découvrent
aujourd'hui l'existence d'un pouvoir
horizontale à 100 dont les gilet jaune
les maires dont on redécouvre l'utilité
80% des débats dans ma région mais
autres france ont été organisées par des
mères vivent les maires bravo le sénat
affirme son indépendance et son
autonomie bravo la république c'est cela
aussi il faut qu'ils se prennent en
compte le nombre
c'est le sort fait un peu sur un certain
populisme en vogue
je dis attention il faut réfléchir
profondément qui ne fait pas les trop
loin trop foncée l elysée pour peut-être
négocier de manière habile donne 10 et
pour être respecté un contre un il
fallait montrer les muscles de toute
façon le il faut aussi prendre un peu de
recul face à cette question c'est à dire
que là
confrontation entre emmanuel macron et
le sénat elle a commencé en juillet 2017
au moment des lois confiance et depuis
c'est un long chemin sinueux où le sénat
à deux en fait de ligne une première
ligne c'est faire de la politique en
s'opposant au gouvernement et là c'est
un peu incarnée par bruno retailleau et
l'autre ligne c'est préserver
l'institution parce qu'on sait jamais
quand même
1969 est encore dans les mémoires au
sénat et donc ça c'est fini
incarnez marché il faudra quand même pas
que le scénar s'opposant trop
frontalement se retrouve réduit au rang
de conseil économique et social et donc
au fil des rythmes politique des
événements des moments tantôt celle une
ligne tantôt c'est l'autre ligne avec
une ligne de crête effectivement qui
n'est pas évidente à gérer mais jusqu'à
maintenant le sénat ne s'est pas trop
mal débrouillé emmanuel macron et je
dirais dans les mois qui viennent c'est
plus emmanuel macron qui a besoin du
sénat que l'averse françoise gatel oui
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on se détache
un peu de légumes des jo je pense qu'il
y à un parti qui est arrivé qui a
renversé la table et qui à un moment a
créé une sorte de d'espérance dans un
nouveau monde où tout le monde suit vrai
comme insolent la réalité est là un peu
plus compliqué que ça et je pense que le
sénat ramène chacune des institutions y
compris le gouvernement à l'exigence de
réfléchir de penser et d'emmener tout un
pays et que il y a en face de lui
effectivement quelqu'un qui n'a pas la
docilité de l'assemblée de par la nature
même de nos élections et je trouve que
c'est très sain y compris pour le
gouvernement
on l'a vu sur la loi mobilité ce matin
parce qu'on est en train d'aider la
ministre des sports des transports
pardon à trouver des solutions que le
sénat à yves en question alors
maintenant voilà le sénat à gaz dérange
quand on aime un avis comme celui-là
mais acceptons nous d'être en démocratie
ou pas et pouvons-nous être intelligent
au delà d'éléments de langage qui
parfois sincèrement gagnerait à être lue
par ceux qui les lisent
bernard extremo franceagrimer le sénat
est toujours constructif il encore ce
matin donc on n'est pas dans une
opposition systématique y compris
d'ailleurs le groupe l'est républicain
c'est pas du tout la culture du sénat et
c'est une grande différence
avec l'assemblée nationale mais ferment
et mais il est indépendant donc il
contrarie souvent la technostructure
d'ailleurs peut-être plus que le
gouvernement bon mais il est pleinement
dans son rôle il faudrait simplement
qu'un gouvernement qui est trop techno
nice par accepter la contribution utile
du sénat et mais là en l'occurrence il
est obligé d'accepter que la parlement
exerce aussi une mission de contrôle
et quand on dit en commission denquête
on ne peut pas mentir c'est aussi bête
que ça mais c'est des règles
fondamentales qu'il faut accepter et
tout ira bien mieux pour tout le monde
merci à vous merci samuel le goff merci
merci éric bocquet on va continuer leur
action avec eux vous atteindra nuit
puisque les socialistes se sont alliés
aux sénateurs et l'air ce matin
justement dans leur boîte vous êtes avec
eux jean pierre sueur un écho rapporteur
de la commission d' enquête sur la
sphère bénin
effectivement jean pierre faire votre
réaction est bien à cette décision qui a
été prise par le bureau du sénat de
transmettre à l'âge la justice notamment
bien sûr les cas d'alexis colère patrick
strzoda et du général lavernhe c'est
pour moi un motif de satisfaction le
certainement pas un motif de
satisfaction
je dirais que c'est une décision qui est
totalement logique
nous avons fait un rapport à ce n'est
pas forcément gagné d'avancé jean pierre
sueur mais j'étais toujours confiant
quant à la logique du sénat pourquoi
voulez vous qu'on change d'avis nous
avons notre campagne
oui mais nous avons fait un rapport
pourquoi nous l'avons nous fait parce
que nous sommes nous avons été
constituée en commission d' enquête
parlementaire
qu'est ce que dit la constitution
article 51 alinéa 2 les commissions d
enquête parlementaire contrôler le
gouvernement évalue les politiques
publiques
nous on était dans notre rôle il y a eu
d'immenses dysfonctionnements très grave
avec monsieur banal à monsieur kraz et
nous c'est impossible que ça se
fonctionne comme ça en plus haut niveau
de l'état dont nous avons reçu beaucoup
de personnes non nées son affaire des
faux témoignages qui ont témoigné et
quand on est devant une commission
denquête parlement tire terre qui
conçoit on doit juré de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité
est-ce que vous jugez que les hauts
fonctionnaires vous ont menti autant que
vincent craza légère d'emballage le
verrou fait le distinguo entre un extra
d'une part et les deux au jour le
fonctionnement
de palmarès je dis que quand un haut
fonctionnaire arrive qu'on lui pose la
question monsieur benalla exerce cette
île des missions de sécurité qu'ils nous
répondent non et qu'après nous
produisons quantité de documents
à commencer par la fiche de poste le
port d'armes etc
des témoignages qui montrent que c'est
faux eh bien c'est faux ce n'est pas la
vérité c'est tout et nous nous sommes là
pour connaître la vérité
donc nous avons fait beaucoup
d'auditions elles ont toutes été public
c'est à dire que tous les français ont
pu voir notre travail
après nous avons publié un rapport pour
dire voilà cela la vérité selon nous
voilà les dysfonctionnements très grave
et voilà les mesures que nous
préconisons pour que ça ne recommence
pas que répondez-vous à la république en
marche on entend déjà et bien la
république en marche qui dit c'était un
procès politique dont l'issue était
connue d'avancé mais c'est faux et moi
vous savez eux
quand j'entends ça je me sens insulté
humilié
je pense qu'on ne respecte pas qu'on dit
que je fais de la politique politicienne
que j'ai un a priori qui est un a priori
politique mais pourquoi j'aurai un a
priori contre la république en marche
c'est un parti démocratique qui joue son
rôle j'ai beaucoup d'amis à la
république aux vaches beaucoup donc
pourquoi on me fait ce procès il ya
aucune raison
j'ai fait un travail vous commandez là
où ça n'a pas marché c'est l'assemblée
nationale où comme la commission des
lois et est présidée par quelqu'un de la
république en marche
non c'est pour des raisons politiques la
demande des instructions mais nous
n'avons demandé aucune instruction nous
sommes des parlementaires de toutes les
sensibilités politiques dans la
commission des lois
constituant commission denquête nous
avons fait notre travail et nous avons
publié un rapport et âme
je vous le dis
tous ceux qui ont lu ce rapport voit
qu'il n'ya rien de faux dans le rapport
et même le gouvernement les a répondu
nous n'ont rien répondu
et il n'y a pas une seule personne ni
dans le gouvernement ni dans la majorité
qui a dit qu'une seule affirmation de
notre rapport était fausse donc ce
rapport il est totalement vrai un mois
sur la contre campagne qu'il y a eu
notamment de la part des centristes pour
justement aller à l'encontre de vos
préparations hervé marseille qui dit il
ya une alliance de circonstance entre
les verts et les socialistes je ne suis
pas dans cette mission d' enquête en
tant que socialiste que l air que rem
que je ne sais pas que communistes non
je suis là en tant qu'un parlementaire
qui avec d'autres parlementaires
applique la constitution est-ce qu'on
veut que dans ce pays il y ait un
pouvoir de contrôle du parlement
si on veut qu'il n'y ait pas de pouvoir
de contrôle du parlement qu'on le dise
mais alors on va être dans une drôle de
république
ça va pas être dans notre tradition et
cl aux pouvoirs de contrôle est exercé
par des parlementaires
ce sont des parlementaires qui ont tous
une étiquette politique
mais ils sont pas là au nom de leur
étiquette politique combien de fois
votre attire le dire à monsieur
marseille qui dit voilà c'est la
collusion mais c'est pas du tout la
collusion nous sommes des parlementaires
nous faisons notre boulot de
parlementaires qui est de rechercher la
vérité nous l'avons fait et alors
aujourd'hui que voulez-vous que disent
le bureau il n'allait pas contredire à
rapport que le gouvernement n'a pas
contredit que rennes n'a pas contredit
la seule chose qui nous est dit c est un
problème de séparation qui nous a été
dit
un problème de séparation du pouvoir
mais il n'y a pas de problème lisez
l'article 51 alinéa de l'article 24 de
la constitution
il n'y a aucun problème de ces aucun
problème donc nommé donc je suis très
clair notre problème c'est la vérité est
ce qu il faut d commission d' enquête
indépendante composée de gens de divers
partis politiques mais on n'est pas là
pour faire de la politique politicienne
merci c'est très important pas de
politique politicienne merci beaucoup
aux gens car j'en ai marre et perdu à
mes questions
s'ils avouent talent on va continuer ce
débat avec eric kerrouche vous êtes un
sénateur socialiste des landes et face à
vos marques
daubresse bonjour vous êtes au sénateur
et l'air du nord tous les deux membres
cette commission des lois qui avait eu
pendant six mois et bien les
prérogatives d'une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire pas de politique
politicienne nous dit jean pierre sueur
éric kerrouche que pourtant on voit et
bien des réactions très vives le sénat a
directement ciblés l'elysée en
s'attaquant aux proches collaborateurs
d'emmanuel macron je ne crois pas que
c'est le sénat qui ait jamais en envoyer
monsieur benalla et monsieur craza la
contrescarpe je ne crois pas non plus
que c'est le sénat qui est outre passé
les fonctions à qu'il avait à
l'intérieur de à l'intérieur de la
présence d'un public il faut quand même
remettre les choses les choses en ordre
cette difficulté
elle vient manifestement d'un
dysfonctionnement au sein de la
présidence de la république
dysfonctionnements sur lequel a enquêté
le sénat parce qu'ils étaient manifestes
et je ne vois pas où est le problème
à part peut-être pour la république en
marche qui a manifestement beaucoup de
mal avec le fonctionnement démocratique
normal c'est un procès politique disent
les porte-paroles justement du parti en
marche martin de brefs écoutez on est
moi j'ai été deux fois ministre
quand vous êtes ministre vos gardes du
corps entre guillemets sont sous
l'autorité du ministre de l'intérieur
quand vous êtes de premier ministre ou
président la république qu'il en est de
même la sécurité du président est
assurée par des personnes qui sont sous
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
toute la sphère benalla ça consistait à
démontrer que monsieur benalla
qu'ils n'avaient pas le statut pour
assurer deux fêtes la sécurité du
président de la république et nous
sommes dans notre rôle de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement
comme l'a très bien rappelé jean-pierre
sueur dans les articles de la
constitution qui la cité où c'est sous
nicolas sarkozy
le président du sénat il était
socialiste est joué parfaitement son
rôle de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement sous emmanuel macron le
président du sénat il appartient aux
républicains mais pour autant il joue
son rôle de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement et donc nous sommes dans le
cadre de la constitution de la vème
république des pouvoirs président obama
est allé trop écouté le problème c'est
que un certain nombre de hauts
fonctionnaires de l'elysée sont cités
dans ce rapport
qu'est ce que vous auriez dit vous les
journalistes alors que tout ça était
publique que vous avez relayer la
commission denquête que le rapport est
public et transparent que les conditions
étaient publiques
si on avait édulcoré ce rapport et qu'on
avait dit il ya deux trois personnes
dont on ne va pas parler parce que ce
sont des haut fonctionnaires de l'elysée
tout à fait respectable on ne met pas en
cause leur respectabilité mais on met en
cause de dysfonctionnement si on avait
fait les choses vous aurez des eaux là
là ils ont eu des pressions de l'elysée
et ils ne vont pas au bout de leurs
rapports on est tout simplement aller au
bout de notre rapport est bien débattue
ce matin lors du bureau du sénat
dans le rapport on dit juste que
manifestement pour les trois personnes
dont on parle il y a eu des omissions ou
en tout cas une vérité qui n'a pas un
qui n'apparaissait pas parfaitement ses
deux seins quand on parlait d'ailleurs
on ne fait que dire on transmet à la
justice et au final c'est quand même la
justice qui va décider ce n'est pas nous
nous on a en conscience jugé que pour
les cas de monsieur b dallas et de
monsieur kraz y avait manifestement des
difficultés qui était évidente est que
pour les trois autres protagonistes
il y en avait également d'un autre ordre
on a encore une fois joué notre rôle
mais je ne comprends pas ce ce rapport
cette difficulté à la démocratie qui est
celle de ce gouvernement de cette
majorité
je rappelle simplement que dans d'autres
pays comme les etats unis
les commissions de contrôle elles sont
bien plus abrupte bien plus rude et que
c'est parfois même des parlementaires du
même parti qui les mène ce que n'a pas
réussi à faire la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale donc c'est le
fonctionnement parlementaire et j'avais
dire que le gouvernement la majorité
doit sans cap doit s'en accommoder comme
tout le monde remarque c'est une
mauvaise on imagine quand même classique
c'est collaborateurs d'elysée sont mis
en examen ça va déstabiliser bien le
pouvoir ça va déstabiliser le plus haut
sommet de l'état on ne peut pas préjuger
de ce que va dire la justice sur les 3/4
viens de citer mon collègue parce que on
signale un certain nombre de choses
il appartient à la justice de qualifier
ces faits par nous de le faire c'est à
elle de le faire et c'est pas peut-être
peut-être qu'ils auront un statut de
témoin assisté peut-être à notre statut
c'est pas à nous de le dire on ne le
sait pas en tout cas on a on est dans
l'article 40 c'est à dire qu'une
commission denquête qu' une commission
d' enquête qui met en évidence de
manière flagrante dans un rapport
extrêmement rigoureux et documenté des
dysfonctionnements qui peuvent relever
du pénal à l' obligation de transmettre
à la justice
et ici comme on est dans une commission
d enquête du sénat le président de la
commission des lois a demandé à ce que
ce soit le bureau du sénat qui prenne
lui-même la décision qui a été prise à
une très large majorité c'est tout voilà
on est dans notre rôle
tout simplement les réformes à venir
notamment la réforme des institutions
est ce que le sénat est affaibli pour
négoce est justement sur cette question
après sept ans ayant permis le sénat a
juste encore une fois jouer son rôle
alors qu'il y ait un rapport de force
politique par ailleurs nul ne l'ignorent
mais enfin qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que en gros si vous n'êtes pas
gentils avec nous on va vous taper sur
les doigts mais sa fin je suis désolé
mais les institutions ne fonctionnent
pas comme ça on a rempli on a rempli
notre rôle est d'ailleurs mon collègue
et raison qu'est ce qu'on n'aurait pas
dit si on avait fait un choix différent
on aurait dit que justement on était les
carpettes de l'exécutive qu' on ne
remplissait pas complètement notre rôle
parce qu'on avait éventuellement heures
par rapport à l'avenir
donc dans un cas comme dans l'autre on
aurait eu des discussions en tout cas
moi je pense que cette discussion
décision était la bonne et puis sur
j'allais dire la réforme
institutionnelle alors réformes
institutionnelles je vais même plus au
monde en dépit ce que ça fait quand même
un nom qu'elle est dans les lames
maintenant sur la réforme
institutionnelle
c'est un autre c'est un autre sujet mais
encore une fois un pouvoir doit savoir
s'accommoder du fait qu'il y à une
opposition et doit savoir s'accommoder
du fait qu'il y a des contre-pouvoirs
c'est le sens de la démocratie mais on
retombe salle des conférences pour une
réaction avec vous êtes en train lui
avec le président justement du groupe
socialiste ici au sénat le sénateur du
nord patrick kanner
oui patrick canard et bien tout d'abord
votre réaction à cette décision du sénat
de transmettre à la justice les cas des
hauts fonctionnaires de l'elysée c'est
une satisfaction pour vous une décision
qui est sage comme il convient au sénat
qui est dans la continuité du travail
exceptionnel qui a été réalisé par cette
commission denquête qui est vraiment à
montrer son sérieux sa pertinence les
conclusions jeunes est partagée et dont
je ne suis pas étonné que le bureau du
sénat
et puis suivre ces conclusions malgré
quelques vote d'abstention ou votre
contre pour certains sénateurs au site
est relativement lâche la montre que les
sna joue son rôle de contre-pouvoir et
jusqu'au bout finalement quand on vous
voir et surtout équilibre des pouvoirs
il fallait que cette décision soit prise
encore une fois nous n'empêcherons qui
n'empièteront pas sur la séparation des
pouvoirs
nous demandons aux pouvoirs judiciaires
de faire son travail d'investigation
après le matériau que nous allons lui
transmettre un très bon matériau et
c'est à la justice de dire si oui ou non
notre sentiment est juste et partagée
pendant précisant bien sûr que les
sénateurs ne sont pas des procureurs et
que c'est la justice
ensuite qui va décider votre réaction au
fait que la république en marche juge
que tout cela est un procès politique
dont l'issue était connue d'avancé
oui enfin c'est l'artillerie lourde là
qui est sorti depuis ce matin par la
public en marche et quelques-uns de ses
alliés procès politique
qu'on nous fait je pense que c'est
plutôt un procès en sorcellerie est ce
que le sénat dérange dans son rôle d'
équilibre des pouvoirs
est-ce qu'il a le droit de travailler de
manière un peu autonome sans la pression
de l'exécutif est ce qu'il a le droit de
dire l'exécutif mais peut-être qu'il ya
eu des problèmes de dysfonctionnement au
sein de l'elysée sur la question de la
sécurité du président bon si on dérange
je le regrette mais en tout cas nous
sommes restés manifestement droits dans
leurs bottes on reprendre une expression
m'a bien célèbre maintenant et surtout
nous montrons français à nos concitoyens
qui nous ont désigné que finalement
avoir deux chambres équilibre est une
bonne chose pour la démocratie il ya eu
toute une contre campagne pendant ces
quelques semaines lors de quelques mets
notamment le président du groupe uc
hervé marseille lui était opposé à
transmettre les cas des trois hauts
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui il juge qu'il
ya une alliance de circonstance entre le
parti socialiste et les ait l'air au
sénat voilà je respecte beaucoup la
position de monsieur marseille
je pense que ses proches sénateurs ont
dû voter contre la décision qui a été
prise ce matin mais c'est sans droit
bien mais bien évidemment parler d'une
alliance
de circonstance je pense que quand même
quand on regarde le passé et du groupe
centriste dans cette maison je pense que
la relation avec keller est quand même
bien plus profonde que celle des
socialistes avec l air est ce que vous
pensez qu aujourd'hui la guerre est
déclarée avec l'exécutif notamment bien
sûr dans le cadre de la révision
constitutionnelle sûrement pas si on
montrait que quelle guerre nous en fait
négociés quand même
aujourd'hui les relations vont être très
tendu ce kit qui souhaitent qu'il serait
terrible c'est que parce que nous ne
nous serions pas en pas virer rang en
osmose avec l'exécutif
on ne fasse des reproches et que
finalement on nous menace en dix ans
mais puisque vous appâter les gentils
avec nous à vous supprimer ou réduire ce
serait totalement scandaleux hélas alors
là nous serions d'une autre hypothèse
j'espère que la raison l'emportera et
que surtout on puisse laisser travailler
la justice dans de bonnes conditions
merci beaucoup patrick kanner d'avoir
répondu à mes questions merci beaucoup
de temps pour cette une nouvelle
réaction et gérard larcher le président
du sénat a réagi je ne suis en guerre
contre personne pas contre l'elysée le
problème est d'une autre nature dit-il
il fallait tout simplement et bien faire
appliquer le droit rien que le droit
tout le droit a dit le président du
sénat mais est d'ailleurs là rapporte
heureux qui a fait son rapport pour que
le bureau puisse se prononcer c'est une
de mes guitares qui est membre du groupe
centriste
donc il n'y a pas eu de confiscation par
un parti poussait canton nous ce nous
nous sommes dans la commission des lois
on a assisté à toute la commission
denquête tout ça a été très consensuel
avec tous les commissaires et chacun pu
poser les questions qu'ils voulaient
poser et tout ça a été fait publiquement
sous le sous le regard de la presse ont
franchement il n'y a pas de problème je
rappelle que quand nicolas sarkozy a
fait la dernière réforme
constitutionnelle qu'est ce qu'il a fait
au final il a donné plus de pouvoir au
peuple
avec les questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité et au parlement on a
renforcé des pouvoirs au parlement et au
peuple pour mieux contrôler les choses
qu'est ce qu'on a entendu dans la sphère
des gilet jaune que le peuple et
notamment les territoires abandonnés
demandé qu'il y ait un peu plus de prise
en compte de ce qui se dit sur le
terrain donc la réforme
constitutionnelle si elle progresse à
nouveau
elle doit aller plutôt dans ce sens là
si on veut vraiment écouter ce qui se
dit en ce moment dans le pays
alors nous on a jamais d'ailleurs été
con
le président larcher n'a jamais été
opposé à ce qu'on réduise le nombre de
parlementaires jeu mais par contre il
doit y avoir une liste doit avoir une
discussion importante pour que des
territoires en particulier ruraux ne
soient pas des territoires abandonnés
dans cette réforme parce que c'est ce
qu'on entend aussi venant du terrain qui
a des territoires qu'ils se sentent des
classes est délaissée donc voilà c'est
ça l'enjeu de la réforme
constitutionnelle c'est pas un enjeu
partisan des uns contre les autres de
tentative d'en faire justement une base
dans les négociations du bureau ce matin
avec moi je suis pas psychanalyse de
l'exécutif je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer là bas
ce que je sais encore une fois c'est que
s'il y a une réforme constitutionnelle
elle ferait bien en effet de tenir
compte de ce qui s'est passé depuis
quelques mois et des attentes qui émerge
non seulement des territoires mais
j'allais dire j'avais dire des français
et que on est pas il ya un moment où
peut-être qu'il faut savoir prendre de
la hauteur
on n'est pas dans une logique là de de
guéguerre politicienne
on est dans une logique où notre pays
traverse une crise qui est difficile et
il faut savoir prendre de la hauteur
mettre les enjeux en perspective pour
savoir répondre justement à cette
situation de blocage
donc si on retombe comme c'est le cas
des déclarations que j'ai pu entendre ce
matin
si on retombe encore dans ces guéguerres
qui sont périmés
je pense qu'on n'a pas du tout du tout
compris le message va poser la question
à françois patriat le président de grupo
la république en marche ici au sénat
elle est à votre micro françois patriat
et bien votre réaction tout d'abord à la
décision du bureau du sénat
je suis surpris et dans le même temps a
dit surpris parce que je pensais que
l'intelligence pouvait l'emporter et que
la mesure pouvait l'emporter
je suis indigné parce que parce que le
l'opposition nationale à utiliser
l'institution du sénat pour faire une
opération de règlement de compte
politique et politicien vous ne
reconnaîtrez afin qu'une solution de
faux témoignages dans les trois hauts
fonctionnaires de l'elysée je crois
d'abord d'abord traduire en justice pour
des suspicions et en tout cas pour un
seul déjà et pour les deux autres pas
pour patrick strzoda effective vous
imaginez aux autres ou alors ils ont
besoin que les gens qui a rien qui a
rien n'y a pas d'éléments mais on
transmet pour le cas où
donc je pense que là il ya eu à travers
les circonvolutions de langage à travers
toutes les précautions qui sont prises
derrière le masque est tombé
si la marche de trop pour le sénat
aujourd'hui de vouloir régler des
comptes politiques
alors qu'on sait très bien que leur
arrière pensée c'est de mettre en cause
l'honneur et la dignité de hauts
fonctionnaires qui ne sont pas
politiques qui ont répondu avec toute
franchise à la commission de mettre en
cause aujourd'hui leur honneur et leur
dignité
vora leur innocence je trouve ça d'une
gravité extrême est la référence 15
jours de procès politique
vous iriez aussi loin pour dire que la
majorité sénatoriale fait valoir son
indépendance le fait que les sna était
dans un rôle de contre-pouvoir mais
attendez le sénat n'est pas là pour
contrôler l'exécutif est là pour
contrôler le gouvernement
le rôle du pouvoir c'est de contrôler
devant ce n'est pas de s'instaurer comme
un juge éventuelle avant la justice qui
désigneraient déjà les coupables alors
qu'il n'a pas les éléments de preuve
suffisants je précise que c'est quand
même à la justice de statuer le sauna se
contente de transmettre bien sûr les
cadets et témoignages de ses honoraires
il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique
cette transmission le mal est fait il
attaque contre l'exécutif et les réelles
vaut bien ses arrière pensées je
l'entends comme tel je le prends comme
tel je considère aujourd'hui que je le
savais déjà que la commission qui de
flou en flou de recherche recherche
voulait à tout prix alors qu'elle n'a
rien découvert la justice et la suisse
ont cours sur les affaires et de
surcroît de quoi elle ne fait pas la
différence entre sur les cinq mis en
cause aujourd'hui sur les deux qui sont
poursuivis pour une action en justice
les trois autres qui ne sont pas ya
aucune différence on voit bien là
l'amalgamme l'objectif c'était pas
tellement le benalla mse kraz c'était
l'objectif c'est d'atteindre des
collaborateurs du chef de l'état et ça
que c'est un dit parce que c'est de la
manoeuvre politicienne de bas étage
merci beaucoup france a pas de rire dans
votre réaction
merci merci tu as mais ça ne va pas
manquer de faire réagir les deux
sénateurs présents sur ce plateau c'est
indigne a dit françois patriat c'est de
la manoeuvre politicienne de bas étage
dit il je trouve qu'ils sont mauvais
dans leurs réactions parce que c'est eux
qui de fait font de la politique
politicienne en disant ça relisez ce
rapport ce rapport et il est très clair
il a été rigoureux et en même temps je
le dis on s'intéresse au fonctionnement
non pas de la présidence de la
république au fonctionnement de l'état
puisque je le redis c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur qui en charge avec des
fonctionnaires approprié la sécurité du
chef de l'état et donc à l'évidence ça
n'a pas été le cas
il ya des témoignages contradictoires il
ya des parjures probable c'est à la
justice de le dire non mais il fallait
absolument qu'on transmette ce ce
rapport commentaires je me permets de
vous interrompre puisqu'il ya une autre
réaction qui nous attend est là vous
intéresser c'est celle de benjamin
griveaux le porte parole grivot votre
réaction fait que le bureau du sénat se
soit rangée à la demande de la
commission d' enquête et est transmis
devant la justice les cas d'alexis
colère patrick strzoda et du général
lavernhe bien sûr pour vincent kra
d'action bien là c'est une autre
histoire
la première réaction les que nous avons
affaire à une décision politique et un
procès politique dit-on dans vos rangs
c'est une décision politique
il faut que bureau du sénat l'assument
comme telle elle ne repose sur aucun
fondement ni en fait ni en droit au fond
à l'issue de cette procédure les masques
tombent
on est dans un instrumentalisation à des
fins politiques d'une affaire sérieuse
et grave qui a été qui a donné lieu à
des commissions d'enquêté une enquête
judiciaire et une enquête administrative
et ou à un moment où la haute assemblée
devrais je crois marquer l'importance de
la période
on a besoin d'unité nationale où on doit
faire fi des petits jeux politiciens
pour se rendre à l'intérêt général
je crois que la haute assemblée n'est
pas à ce rendez-vous nous on est
extrêmement calme extrêmement déterminé
extrêmement serein et on ne cédera rien
à cette instrumentalisation politique
les sénateurs répondre aux contre
pouvoirs je suis ce que dit bruno
retailleau ce matin et tant pis si
l'idée même de contre-pouvoir n'est pas
encore une notion familière pour
certains ils finiront par s'habituer
c'est politiquement bas et moralement
grave à nouveau le pays a besoin d'unité
nationale a besoin qu'on se rassemble
on se remonte les manches et que on
consacre le temps de travail à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat à
l'essentiel à ce qu'attendent nos
compatriotes à savoir qu'on trouve des
solutions à leurs problèmes et non pas
qu'on utilise une affaire dont j'ai dit
la gravité à des fins strictement
politique pour au fond régler des
comptes personnels
je crois que la haute assemblée mais
mieux que ça et j'ai cru comprendre que
des voix sur les bancs du sénat se sont
élevées depuis cette décision notamment
du côté de thierry c'est pour dire
qu'elle était pour le moins choqué de
cette pratique du pouvoir ce n'est pas
la nôtre ce n'est pas notre conception
du rôle important que joue le sénat dans
nos institutions
l'exécutif avait promis une réponse fois
parfois justement à la au rapport de la
commission denquête qu'en est il ya du
set recours sur le fond l'elysée le fera
vous le savez mais elle a déjà eu
l'occasion de répondre à maintes
recommandations et des treize
recommandations qui ont été faites suite
à la commission
certaines ont d'ailleurs déjà été
engagées ce qui montre que le pouvoir
exécutif que l'elysée est attentif à ce
que le sénat peut dire et remarque le
sénat formule lorsqu il le fait avec
raison et avec mesure
la guerre n'est pas déclarée lorsqu il
le fait avec raison et avec mesure nous
ne sommes ni dans la raison ni dans la
mesure nous sommes dans le coup
politique très bien mais en tout cas
nous on a un seul horizon
l'intérêt général et l'unité du pays
merci beaucoup benjamin griveaux d'avoir
répondu à mes questions mais moi je
trouve que les deux réactions que je
viens d'entendre la pathétique si c'est
triste d'en arriver à ce niveau de la
politique singulièrement pour des
des parlementaires qui ont eu à un
parcours intéressant par le par le passé
au delà de ça je pense qu'il faut être
sérieux je ne pense pas que les français
croient que monsieur benalla incarnent
l'intérêt général et qu'ils fassent se
rassembler derrière lui je n'ai pas eu
cette j'ai pas eu cette impression
franchement je crois juste que il faut
que ce gouvernement
malgré la victoire de sa majorité qui
est importante sachant apprendre d'abord
l'humilité et 2 les règles de la
démocratie
penser qu' on peut marcher sur une
institution parce qu'elle fait des
choses qui ne vous plaît qui ne plaisent
pas qui ne vous agrée pas c'est une
conception complètement complètement
erronée et je crois que l' écoute
longtemps aps
c'est vraiment ce qui manque à ce
gouvernement et emmanuel macron prévu de
travailler là dessus que sur des
accusations qui pourraient conserver le
sénat
il ya beaucoup d'amateurisme vous savez
la plupart des personnes pas tout mais
la plupart des personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui dans l'exécutif soit à
l'elysée soit au gouvernement n'exerçait
pas ou peu de responsabilités nationales
ou locales avant et on voit bien qu'ils
ont eu du mal à apprivoiser ce qu'est
notre l'exercice du pouvoir et de la
constitution quand bruno retailleau
parle de contre-pouvoir il ne fais que
citer l'esprit des lois de montesquieu
sur lequel repose beaucoup de principes
de notre république
quelles que soient les régimes et il est
arrivé ici je le redis il est arrivé au
sénat de dire des choses qui ne plaisait
pas au président de la république de
l'époque qui était monsieur sarkozy mais
il l'a dit parce qu'il était dans son
rôle que voilà c'est tout et donc on ne
peut pas transgresser ces principes et
je pense que il ya beaucoup
d'amateurisme et c'est pas tout à fait
ce qu'attendent les français les
français attendent qu'on fasse notre
boulot tout simplement
et dans notre boulot il ya bien sûr de
voter des lois mais aussi de contrôler
l'action du gouvernement
bien merci à vous a marqué film de brad
merci à eric kerrouche regagné
l'hémicycle avant la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement avant de la
semaine dernière
action et vous le thème traduit avec
justement hervé marseille le président
concentré oui effectivement
eh bien vous massez votre réaction à la
décision du bureau du sénat qui transmet
donc à la justice
les cas des trois hauts fonctionnaires
de l'elysée vous-même n'y étiez pas
favorable nous l'aviez dit très tôt
seulement le bureau du sénat a tranché
il a travaillé ce matin il a pris des
décisions je les respecte et j'en prends
acte
pour autant je continue à regretter
certaines d'entre elles elles étaient
inutiles superfétatoire la commission
denquête sous l'autorité de philippe bas
avaient bien travaillé
il y avait eu un sans faute tout le
monde avait remarqué que ça d'ailleurs
évoluer les rapports sont trois lames et
maintenant on va un peu plus loin
concernant deux hauts fonctionnaires
tout à fait respectable pour des sujets
qui ne me paraissent pas être fondées on
souhaite envoyer leur dossier chez le
procureur de la république je le
regrette je le déplore
et je pense que c'est inutile et
superfétatoire voici donc une décision
politique a été prise par le bureau du
sénat
en faisant cela c'est l'intérêt aussi
non je ne veux pas croire seul instant
que tout ça était guidée par des
considérations politiques mais seulement
juridique
en tout état de cause si certains
veulent faire de la politique et bien
qu'ils aillent devant les électeurs et
pas dans les prétoires c'est pas là que
ça se fait et vous dénoncez le
raisonnement juridique pour vous c'est
trop fragile on va pas se raconter des
histoires il est facile d'habiller
juridiquement un certain nombre de
choses c'est commode je continue de
penser qu'il ya eu un très bon travail
qui a été fait par la commission
denquête aller chercher ces hauts
responsables c'était inutile et
superfétatoire
ça n'apporte rien ça n'ajoute rien ça ne
craque des complexification entre notre
assemblée le sénat et l'exécutif
est-ce que cela met à mal et bien
l'alliance qu'il ya ici au sénat entre
le groupe uc et le groupe ait l'air vous
d'ailleurs qui avait dénoncé une
alliance de circonstance entre le groupe
ps et le groupe ait l'air ce matin oui
j'ai constaté que les républicains
étaient dans cette affaire associés si
je puis dire aux socialistes c'est
novateur
je ne veux pas croire là encore que cela
préjuge d'une égale à lyon rapporteur la
setil se tiennent au vent bon je pense
quand même que il faut raison garder il
ya une majorité
nous travaillons sous l'autorité de
gérard larcher et je salue le travail
qu'il accomplit et qu'il a encore
accompli aujourd'hui au bureau alors que
certains voulaient le pousser dans ses
retranchements un peu plus loin je
trouve ça dommageable et il faut que la
raison revienne parce qu'en france il se
passe des choses et ce qu'attendent de
nous les français c'est des solutions à
leurs difficultés
est-ce que vous pour vous et justement
bien c'est la crise ouverte avec
l'exécutif dans le cadre de la révision
constitutionnelle il faut que chacun
garde eu raison et il faut essayer de
trouver des oies d'apaisement je suis
sûr évidemment que oui ça irrite c'est
normal mais au delà des hommes il ya les
institutions encore une fois ça fait
dix-huit semaines que des gens
manifestent sur les champs elysées il ya
des blessés la france est regardée
bon faut qu'on trouve des solutions aux
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat faut qu'on
trouve des solutions
également à la fracture territoriale
c'est avec les chambres que ça se ferait
avec l'exécutif il faut trouver les
voies de l'apaisement
merci beaucoup hervé marseille d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et on va tout de
suite bien rejoindre l'hémicycle nous
attend alexandre plus tard alexandre
pour l'ordre du jour de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
et oui tam et dessinateurs vont revenir
sur les violences du week-end dernier
pendant les manifestations des gilet
jaune
puisque le gouvernement prépare sa
riposte sécuritaire pour le week-end
prochain pour l'acte 19 de
manifestations d gilet jaune
l'information importante c'est que les
soldats de l'opération antiterroriste
sentinelle vont apporter du renfort le
week-end prochain notamment pour
sécuriser les lieux sensibles comme le
palais de l'elysée un choix du président
de la république
emmanuel macron pour permettre aux
policiers de mieux gérer les
manifestations et de mieux disperser les
attroupements interdits le week-end
prochain notamment sur les champs
elysées alors ce renfort de l'armée il
est critiqué par tous les principaux
opposants de la classe politique et
notamment bruno retailleau le patron des
sénateurs les républicains qui a demandé
au président et au président de la
république chef des armées de renoncer à
cette décision funeste alors ce matin le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner a intronisé son nouveau préfet
de police
didier lallement qui est nommé alors que
l'ancien a été limogé cette semaine
l'ancien préfet de police de paris
michel delpech christophe castaner qui
ce matin a affirmé que le week-end
prochain
il y aurait une il y aurait une impunité
0 à noter que pour cette séance de
questions d'actualité le premier
ministre edouard philippe sera absent
c'est la cloche va sonner ses débuts de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
c'est la raison de la présence dans
notre hémicycle du drapeau de la
francophonie et celui de l'assemblée
parlementaire de la francophonie à
l'invitation de françois paradis
président de l'assemblée nationale du
québec et président de l'assemblée
parlementaire de la francophonie
nous allons procéder nous procédons à
cette célébration de concert avec le
parlement des pays de la grande famille
francophone car la francophonie c'est
l'appartenance à une communauté humaine
de plus de 200 millions de personnes à
travers le monde
c'est un trait d'union entre des
cultures et les sociétés très diverses
mais qui ont en partage en seulement une
langue mais les valeurs et les idéaux
qu'elle porte le dialogue la tolérance
le respect de la diversité des droits de
l'homme en un mot ce qui les résume peut
être tous la démocratie se tient à
saluer l'assemblée parlementaire de la
francophonie à tous nos collègues qui y
siègent et qui en défendent les valeurs
je remercie plus particulièrement le
vice président délégué de la section
française notre collègue philippe
mouillé et christophe andré frassa
président de la commission politique est
notre collègue claudine lepage vice
présidente de la commission des affaires
parlementaires pour leur engagement dans
ce combat
mes chers collègues la langue française
est la seconde langue des organisations
internationales
parfois il faut combattre pour la
conserver à ce rang la troisième langue
des affaires la quatrième langue de
l'internet ne sous-estimons pas les
réalisations les promesses entre les
riches ne sous-estimons pas l'atout que
représente pour nous la francophonie que
nous devons défendre et promouvoir et
c'est un combat de tous les instants en
notamment les parlementaires dans les
relations entre parlements du monde et
des parlementaires de langue francophone
ont une responsabilité particulière
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que notre séance et
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
sur notre site internet au nom du bureau
chacun sera attentif à respecter son
temps et au respect des uns et des
autres et je donne la parole à notre
collègue guillaume gontard pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
vendredi dernier les secrétaires d'état
à tata les poires sont manifestés avec
lessive les lycéens pour la sauvegarde
du climat
je me félicite que la france par le
biais de vous de votre gouvernement soit
ainsi à la pointe du combat pour la
prévert préservation de l'environnement
malheureusement le ministère de
l'économie et des finances n'a pas été
informé à temps de l'initiative
en effet dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi juste avant l'ouverture de la
semaine sans pesticides
la majorité parlementaire avec la
bénédiction de bercy haddad adopté un
amendement au projet de loi pacte pour
repousser de trois ans à 2025
l'interdiction de la production en
france de pesticides pourtant interdit
d' usage dans l'union européenne
vous me rétorquerez que le sénat avait
purement et simplement supprimé cette
interdiction et vous aurez raison
mais je note que le gouvernement ne
s'était alors pas opposé à ces
amendements rétrograde
bilan des opérations la france va
continuer à produire pendant six ans des
pesticides tellement dangereux pour
l'être humain tellement nocif pour nos
sols que l'union européenne les a
interdits
sur son territoire la même union
européenne qui tergiverse toujours sur
le glyphosate pourtant reconnu pour la
deuxième fois comme cancérigène par la
justice américaine
c'est dire le niveau de dangerosité des
produits en question
mais ce qui est dangereux pour les
européens ne l'est visiblement pas pour
le reste de l'humanité et la france va
pouvoir continuer a empoisonné pendant
six ans les agriculteurs des autres
continents alors que le président est
revenu sur sa promesse de sortie du
glyphosate en trois ans le ministre de
l'agriculture confirmé pourtant dans le
même temps la dangerosité du produit
conséquence la politique du gouvernement
est parfaitement illisible
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
enfin proposer une politique ambitieuse
de sortie des pesticides ou bien confier
cette mission à la fnsea et industriels
phyto phytopharmaceutiques comme le
laisse à penser la signature du
gouvernement aux véritables contrats de
duke dix contrats de solutions
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
d'état ministre de transition écologique
et solidaire madame emmanuelle wargon
adam la ministre veut la parole monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gontard
je vous remercie de cette question qui
va me permettre de revenir sur notre
ambition en matière de produits
phytosanitaires
cette ambition est forte nous nous
sommes engagés à diminuer l'utilisation
de ces produits de 50% d'ici à 2025
nous avons avancé avec la séparation de
la vente et du conseil qui sera
opérationnelle en 2019 et nous avons
augmenté la redevance pour pollutions
diffuses également opérationnel au 1er
janvier 2019 en matière de glyphosate et
vous le savez la france est le pays qui
a poussé l'union européenne à noeux
réautoriser cette substance que pour
cinq ans et nous pour 15 et non pour 15
ans et une en france nous avons pris
l'engagement de sortir du glyphosate en
trois ans cet engagement est aussi un
engagement d'accompagner toutes les
filières pour ne laisser aucune filière
au bord de la route et trouver des
solutions qui permettent une production
durable en france 110 fosad ces
solutions sont travaillés dans le
contrat de solution avec la fnsea mais
aussi avec le monde de la recherche avec
la pca et avec tous les acteurs du monde
de l'agriculture
en ce qui concerne l'exportation le
récent vote de la loi pacte à
l'assemblée nationale a décalé à 2025
l'interdiction de production
d'utilisation et de
stockage de tous les produits y compris
ceux qui ne sont pas autorisés dans
l'union européenne
nous sommes le seul pays de l'union
européenne à avoir pris cette décision
et cette interdiction
nous souhaitons que cette interdiction
soit partagée au niveau européen et
c'est l'une des raisons pour laquelle
nous avons accepté le décalage jusqu'à
2025 pour pouvoir porter ce projet à
bruxelles ce sujet à bruxelles et à
avoir une politique communautaire
offensive en la matière nous souhaitons
aussi accompagner la filière
au lieu d'aller à une simple
interdiction nous allons accompagner les
producteurs pour que eux-mêmes changent
leurs pratiques et pour qu'ils puissent
proposer aux agriculteurs en dehors de
l'europe des solutions qui n'utilisent
plus ces produits
la politique que nous menons est bien
une politique ambitieuse de sortie mais
c'est aussi une politique de
transformation et nous accompagnons les
filières en ce sens merci la parole
non monsieur bocquet
[Applaudissements]
quelle gloire monsieur bocquet la parole
de notre collègue jean marc todeschini
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adressait aussi à monsieur le premier
ministre
depuis le début de la crise sociale le
17 novembre dernier vous avez géré dans
l'improvisation absolue les réponses au
mouvement de contestation ainsi que la
sécurisation de ces manifestations
tout le monde est en tête les
déclarations du président de la
république le 10 décembre
venant contredire les propos de ces
ministres y compris ceux du premier
ministre tenu quelques jours auparavant
le 10 décembre n'a été en fait que le
début d'une ère de contradictions et
d'improvisation qui trouve son paroxysme
avec l'annoncent en conseil des
ministres du recours à l'armée pour les
manifestations de samedi prochain
le groupe socialiste avait déposé dès le
3 décembre
ces propositions pour sortir de la crise
cela passait par l' écoute et par un
dialogue sincère avec les français et
les élus nationaux et locaux
nous avions également condamné les
violences du 1er décembre comme les
violences dans toutes les manifestations
mais enfermé dans vos certitudes
vous n'avez toujours pas trouvé les
chemins pour sortir de la crise ont
quatre mois en laissant pourrir la
situation en jouant sur
l'affaiblissement progressif de la
contestation nous avait offert aux
casseurs un terrain propice pour leur
violence
vous êtes les seuls responsables de la
situation actuelle
en décidant d'appeler les militaires
vous prenez une très grande
responsabilité
vous devez expliquer aux français dans
quel cadre vous plantez employés des
militaires
quelles consignes leur ont été données
seront ils autorisés à le faire usage de
leurs armes en cas de débordements
quelle liste distinction est faite entre
délinquants eni nous avons besoin
d'éclaircissements suite aux
déclarations contradictoires de vos
ministres retirer des militaires de
l'opération sentinelles pour les mettre
sur le maintien de l'ordre c'est aussi
affaiblir la sécurité des français dans
les gares dans les aéroports sur les
marchés face à la menace terroriste
vous exposez enfin bruno militaire vous
prenez le risque de déstabiliser
institution qui est mobilisé et dédiée
depuis 2015 à la lutte contre le
terrorisme
voulez vous réellement prendre le risque
d'affaiblir les militaires en les
embarquant dans une polémique
s'il devait y avoir des blessés par
balles voire pire on vous réforme la
parole et à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe qu'est-ce que
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs center monsieur le sénateur
j'aurais tout de suite vous rassurer
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire ce
matin à la préfecture de police
il est bien évidemment pas question que
les maudites les militaires de
sentinelle soit à la fois détournés de
leur fonction qui est celle de dans le
cadre de sentinelle de protéger les
français du risque terroriste de
protéger les français face à des tueries
de masse est d'être présent partout
partout en france et dans paris en
particulier il n'est pas question
d'utiliser les forces armées les
militaires pour gérer l'ordre public
tout simplement parce que et vous l'avez
dit dans votre question et vous avez une
expérience de ministre au ministère des
armées vous le savez ils ont de très
grandes qualités mais ils ne sont pas
formés ni équipés pour gérer l'ordre
public et donc samedi prochain
comme pour les samedis passé depuis le
mouvement le début du mouvement des
gilets jaunes
mais comme depuis 2015 les militaires de
sentinelle seront là pour épauler les
français dans l'enjeu de sécurité ils
seront là pour épauler aussi nos forces
de sécurité sur ces sujets là mais pas
pour gérer l'ordre public
à certains endroits ils se substitueront
ils se substitueront pour garder des
bâtiments qui ne seront pas exposés à un
risque de manifestations
ils se substitueront pour libérer des
forces qui elles seront des forces de
police ou de gendarmes qui elles seront
mobilisés pour assurer la gestion de
l'ordre public
voilà monsieur le sénateur mesdames les
sénateurs j'ai vu la polémique suite à
l'information qui avait été communiquée
par le porte parole qui donnait juste
l'information que oui
les militaires de sentinelle seraient
mobilisés samedi prochain comme ils
l'ont été systématiquement depuis le 17
novembre il ya eu un emballement cet
emballement peut-être clos immédiatement
et je tiens à vous rassurer
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le midi
d'abord relève notre collègue emmanuel
capus pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires ddt avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
148 coups de fouet trente trois ans de
prison
pas pour avoir tabassé un policier sur
les champs elysées pas pour avoir tenté
de brûler vive une femme et son bébé
non n'en déplaise aux révolutionnaires
de plateaux télé qui samedi après samedi
proclame avec des trémolos dans la voix
que nous vivons dans une dictature
je ne parle pas de la france non mes
chers collègues 148 coups de fouet et 33
ans de prison c'est la condamnation le 8
mars dernier de nasrin sotoudeh avocate
iranienne par un tribunal de téhéran
son crime mes chers collègues avoir
défendu ses clientes des femmes qui
retiraient leur voile en public
pire avoir contesté publiquement le port
obligatoire du voile nasrin sotoudeh
défenseurs des droits des femmes
lauréate du prix sakharov 2012 décerné
par le parlement européen la france
monsieur le ministre doit défendre et
soutenir ou qu'ils se trouvent celles et
ceux qui comme elles mettent en jeu leur
propre sécurité pour défendre les
libertés fondamentales pour défendre les
valeurs universelles qui fondent notre
république et au premier rang d'entre
elles la liberté religieuse
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
et les droits de la défense
nasrin sotoudeh a renoncé à faire appel
car elle croit sa cause perdue mais de
très nombreux soutiens de par le monde
refuse de s'y résoudre
comme en témoigne en france et pétitions
qui se multiplient monsieur le ministre
ma question est très simple croyez-vous
également sa cause perdue monsieur le
ministre
la france va-t-elle intensifier son
action afin d'obtenir la libération
immédiate et inconditionnelle de nasrin
sotoudeh
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre dans la parole et au
ministre de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur jean yves le drian
au monsieur le sénateur le cas de madame
sotoudeh suscite l'indignation
l'indignation à travers le monde et vous
aurez les faits étaient tous à l'instant
le porte parole
et cette indignation le gouvernement la
partage pleinement d'abord parce qu'elle
a été condamnée dans des conditions à
urt e-sante ensuite parce qu'elle a eu
des peines lourdes que vous avez
évoquées y compris des coups de fouet
ensuite parce qu'il s'agit d'une avocate
condamné comme avocate
il s'agit d'une femme condamnée pour
avoir défendu les droits des femmes et
en particulier celles qui comptent s en
iran l'obligation du voile islamique
et enfin parce que madame ce dossier est
un symbole son engagement plus a valu en
2012 le prix sakharov du parlement
européen
il lui a valu aussi cet engagement des
arrestations d emprisonnement des
pressions c'est pourquoi comme vous le
savez le président de la république a
publiquement appelé à l'occasion de la
remise du premier prix simone veil à sa
libération
c'est pourquoi le président a rappelé
qu'à souhaiter dans le cadre du g7 de la
faire symboliquement membre du conseil
consultatif pour l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et je redirai cela
à la tribune des nations unies puisque
vous le savez la france préside le
conseil de sécurité en ce moment et je
l'assurait la semaine prochaine alors on
fait des efforts considérables
ces derniers mois avec les rangs pour
préserver l'accord nucléaire en dépit de
décrets du retrait américain
nous le faisons parce que nous honorons
nos signatures mais l'iran doit aussi
respecter ses engagements et en
particulier ceux du pacte international
relatif aux droits civils et politiques
et notre souci de préserver l'accord de
vienne n'est pas un blanc-seing accordé
à l'iran et certainement pas en matière
des droits de l'homme c'est pourquoi
nous ferons tout pour obtenir la
libération de madame sotoudeh merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue philippe dominati pour le
groupe l'est républicain
j'avais apparu chez le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur car le limogeage
justifier du préfet de police est un
événement sans précédent sous l'histoire
d'un cinquième république le sénat n'a
pas manqué d'alerter le gouvernement il
ya eu la commission denquête de mon
collègue gros didier la loi
anti-casseurs du président retailleau à
deux reprises le budget pourtant
régalien a été rejetée par cette
assemblée le budget du ministère de
l'intérieur
il ya eu une demande de la cour des
comptes j'ai moi même proposé un rapport
sur la commission des finances sur le
renseignement intérieur et sur la
préfecture de police
malgré cela quatre mois après le saccage
de l'arc de triomphe et les champs
elysées sont en ruine la france veut
propager l'image de la paix en afrique
en shihri mais elle est incapable de la
purée au parisien à quelques encablures
de l'elysée
alors ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur dans quels
délais vous vous engager vis-à-vis de
vos hommes vis-à-vis des parisiens
vis-à-vis des français à rétablir
l'ordre
la parole est au secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur laurent du lez
monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur philippe dominati
vous évoquez donc les d'abord le
limogeage du préfet de police ensuite
les incidents graves très graves qu'il y
a eu samedi dernier effectivement sur
les champs-elysées vous évoquez quatre
mois de tension extrême je vais vous
rappeler que et vous avez raison de
rappeler les incidents très graves qu'il
y a eu le 1er décembre sur les
champs-elysées qui nous avaient conduits
avec christophe castaner immédiatement
et de manière totalement inédite à
revoir totalement la doctrine de gestion
de l'ordre public hors donnant comme
nous le demandaient les policiers comme
nous le demander les policiers les
organisations syndicales de policiers
beaucoup de mobilité de réactivité de
capacité d'interpellation et de
déconcentration des pouvoirs de décision
et samedi après samedi pardon mais vous
ne pouvez pas parler de cas au samedi
après samedi il y a eu le 8 décembre il
y a eu dès samedi où nous avons évité
tant d'exactions temps de pillage et
peut-être même monsieur le sénateur
philippe dominati peut-être même des
morts vous savez que c'est un curseur
important en matière de gestion de leur
public et c'était partout vrai à paris
comme en province
alors oui samedi samedi dernier il y a
eu un vrai dysfonctionnement car cette
doctrine réactive d'interpellations elle
n'a pas été mise en ordre et en oeuvre
pardon alors même que nous avions donné
des instructions extrêmement précises
avec christophe castaner en ce sens et
c'est ce qui nous a conduit à renforcer
encore plus sa doctrine et comme vous le
savez le premier ministre a annoncé
désormais tout attroupement qui risquent
de présenter un caractère volent violent
sera immédiatement dispersés et seront
prises à l'appui de ces mesures
des arrêtés d'interdiction qui seront
conclus avec chacun des maires concernés
et qui permettront de venir appuyer ces
mesures de dispersion d'attroupement
mais permettez moi d'insister vous le
savez très bien monsieur le sénateur
philippe dominati vous savez très bien
qu'à paris des débordements matière
d'ordre public il y en a eu plein
d'autres et sous d'autres quinquennat
sous d'autres quinquennat et il faut
toujours savoir apprécier ces questions
d'ordre public et se lancer aux
fonctionnaires spécialistes des
questions de sécurité qui vous le dis
avec beaucoup de modestie et d'humilité
car entre 2007 et 2012 il ya aussi
beaucoup d'incidents en matière d'ordre
public
messieurs dominati tout d'abord je
voudrais faire une observation
en préambule le fait monsieur neige que
vous me répondiez vous attire la
sympathie de cet hémicycle
car nous avons tous compris que vous
étés le prochain fusible ma question
s'adresser au ministre de l'intérieur le
ministre de l'intérieur qui a peu de
temps était le chef d'un parti politique
qui dans 18 circonscriptions à paris et
représentée par quatorze parlementaires
et on dirait pourtant que le
gouvernement est sourd il entend pas
l'exaspération des parisiens il entend
pas le désespoir de ceux qui ne peuvent
plus travailler
il n'entend pas partout même à la
périphérie
le fait que le touriste l'activité
économique la justice la délinquance
l'antisémitisme explose parce que vous
n'arrivez pas à résoudre un problème et
à paris le parisien souffre déjà des
difficultés provoquées par la mairie est
en réalité nous sommes nous ici
victime de la double peine l'unc
considération du gouvernement
l'incompétence de la mairie et c'est en
cela que je voulais exprimer quelque
chose
obéniche de l'intérieur si les copies
merci
la parole est à madame catherine
fournier pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole madame la
présidente
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresser à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
mon propos portent sur la grève des
douaniers déclenché le 4 mars dernier
sur fond de break si tu laisses effet se
sont vite fait sentir des perturbations
importantes en gare du nord sur les
eurostar et un blocage complet de calais
calais pris en otage une fois de plus
une fois de trop
ce mouvement de contestation de dure
depuis près de trois semaines des
contrôles zélés sporadiques effectué au
port et au tunnel sous la manche blocs
de manière insupportable tout
déplacement normale sur les principaux
axes de circulation
les conséquences pour le territoire sont
désastreuses je vous les énumère des
camions à l'arrêt des heures sur les
bandes d'arrêt d'urgence jusqu'à 9
heures des chauffeurs sans information
sans ravitaillement sans sanitaires des
résidents qui se voit bloqué à des
entrées ou des sorties d'autoroute fermé
et non pré signaler sans information
sans indication de déviation sans
filtrage les salariés accusent des
retards sur leur lieu de travail les
artisans des difficultés à se rendre sur
leurs chantiers
les commerces sont désertés les sociétés
sont en attente de leur livraison et les
transporteurs locaux exemple est excédé
c'est une perturbation de trop qui sème
la colère
monsieur le ministre nous avons appris
au travers des de la crise des gilet
jaune que laisser pourrir une situation
c'est semer et accentuer le
mécontentement qu'elle est est un port
de combes est un point de convergence
routier qui fonctionne à flux tendu on
doit le gérer dans son exception
l'activité économique du calaisis et le
trafic transmanche sont donc suspendus
au piétinement des négociations entre
l'état et ses agents nous avons besoin
d'un signal fort pouvez vous présenter
les moyens que vous comptez mettre en
place pour arrêter ce mouvement de grève
merci
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès d'immigration
des comptes publics monsieur olivier
dussopt up la parole monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice fourni vous nous interroger
sur le mouvement de grève des douaniers
avec deux points qui concentre le plus
de difficultés la gare du nord à paris
vous avez évoqué et la région de calais
avec des conséquences économiques que
vous avez rappelé et qui pénalise le
territoire nous avons apporté des
réponses aux douaniers nous avons
apporté des réponses dans le cadre de la
préparation du bric site avant ce
mouvement avec la programmation et dès
2019 la création de plusieurs centaines
de postes douaniers pour faire face aux
briques site dans des conditions
correctes sans avoir à se retirer des
forces douanières dans d'autres points
du territoire depuis le début de ce
mouvement
les douaniers les organisations
syndicales qu'il représente ont été
reçus par le ministre de l'action et des
comptes publics gérald darmanin et à
plusieurs reprises par le directeur
général des douanes
nous leur avons proposé deux types de
mesures une mesure immédiate qui
consiste en une revalorisation salariale
de plus de 50 euros nets à compter du
1er juillet pour les 17000 douaniers et
cela représente un engagement de 14
millions d'euros
nous leur avons aussi proposé d'ouvrir
des chantiers complémentaires sur la
question des conditions de travail c'est
sur la base des propositions nous avons
formulé que les discussions se
poursuivent mais je tiens à dire devant
vous que dans l'attenté de
l'aboutissement de ces discussions
il est impératif que le trafic puisse
reprendre dans de bonnes conditions et
nous avons donné consigne instruction et
gendarmes anaya veillait tout
particulièrement que des sanctions
soient prises contre les actions qui
viennent contrevenir au bon
fonctionnement des infrastructures de
l'économie et de la circulation libre
des marchandises comme des personnes je
saisis l'occasion de votre question pour
ajouter deux choses la première pour
dire que les perturbations qui sont le
fruit de ce mouvement de grève n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec la réalité
projeté après le break site pour une
raison toute simple les contrôles
sporadiques et les mouvements que vous
évoquez contrôles concernent des sorties
du territoire alors que dans le cas du
break site
nous aurons à contrôler les entrées ce
qui démontre l'absence totale de lien
avec la réalité projeté la deuxième
chose que je veux souligner devant vous
et devant toute votre assemblée c'est le
fait que
le premier ministre nous a demandé à
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
de préparer toutes les hypothèses de
briques sites y compris un vrai site
sans accord c'est dans ce cadre que nous
travaillons nous comptons suédois nés
mais nous comptons sur l'engagement pour
mettre fin à ces perturbations
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à notre collègue bernard but pour le
groupe de la république en marge avait
la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des solidarités de la santé il
ya quelques jours à peine le 8 mars dans
une communion quasiment unanime nous
célébrions la journée internationale des
droits des femmes
à cette occasion nombre d'entre nous
rendions hommage à ces femmes qui ont
mené des combats pour que leur droit à
vingt son fil des années je pense ici
plus particulièrement à celles qui
étaient à votre place madame la ministre
simone veil
je pense à elles et au combat courageux
qu'elle a menées en 1976 à contre
courant de sa famille politique à
l'époque pour que les femmes puissent
disposer de leur corps et choisir de
donner la vie ou pas parce qu'en fait tu
n étais pas leur choix grâce à simone
veil le droit à l'avortement était enfin
légale en france
madame la ministre ce droit fondamental
des femmes de disposer de leur corps est
en danger pas uniquement aux états unis
où des intégristes anti-avortement
s'enchaînent sur les grilles des
cliniques pratiquant cet acte médical
ce danger est aussi présent ici en
france et qui plus est commandité par
des médecins
comment est il possible que le syndicat
national des gynécologues-obstétriciens
par la voix de son président puisse
menacer le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse pour faire
pression sur vous madame et sur votre
gouvernement
ce syndicat a menacé d'une grève des ivg
s'ils n'obtenaient pas satisfaction sur
les dédommagements demandés dans des
erreurs médicales manifeste quelle est
leur déontologie médicale pour oser une
telle menace
le président du syndicat national des
gynécologues-obstétriciens n'en est
malheureusement pas son premier acte
anti ivg
il ya quelques mois à peine en septembre
dernier il déclaré publiquement qu'ils
considéraient l'avortement comme un
crime
se défendant peu après d'affiché là une
conviction personnelle
madame la ministre aujourd'hui je suis
et nous sommes tous partagés entre la
colère et la honte de tels comportements
pour les représentants d'une corporation
médicale
alors madame la ministre je vous
remercie de nous expliquer quel est
votre positionnement face à de tels
agissements et comment vous pouvez nous
assurer que vous serez la garante d'un
droit fondamental des femmes le droit
léger et de choisir ainsi d'avoir ou non
un enfant pour nous raconte d'accord les
cas la secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
dentiste du golf vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames la
sénatrice mais c'est le sénateur
monsieur le sénateur au préalable je
vous prie d'excuser l'absence de la
ministre mais amusant étant retenu à
l'assemblée nationale sur le pour
l'examen du projet de loi santé monsieur
le sénateur comme vous nous jugeons ce
communiqué du syndicat national des
gynécologues et obstétriciens de france
totalement scandaleux ils menacent d'un
refus spécifique d'un acte et pas
n'importe lequel le refus de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est un acte militant
un acte signifiant ce n'est pas digne
d'un syndicat dès que la ministre des
solidarités et de la santé en a eu
connaissance à la dénoncer le caractère
inadmissible de ces menaces destinées à
se faire entendre
vous l'avez dit ces menaces vont à
l'encontre du respect inconditionnel du
droit à l'image est garantie d'un autre
pays
ces nouvelles déclarations sont
inacceptables de la part d'un syndicat
qui entend représenter les gynécologues
obstétriciens cette profession doit être
plus près des souffrances des femmes est
d'accompagner ces dernières notamment
dans ce moment très difficile et très
douloureux qu'elle interruption
volontaire de grossesse mais sachez en
aucun cas qu'une telle prise en otage
des femmes ne servira de levier de
négociation au sein de notre ministère
en aucun cas une telle prise d'otage des
femmes ne peut non plus servir à la
médiation d'un dossier en tout cas si
médiation il ya eu elle ne met pas à
l'honneur ce syndicat ni les
professionnels qu'ils représentent et je
le regrette nous le regrettons vivement
je vous remercie
merci la parole et un autre collègue et
rigole pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à la
ministre en charge de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
madame la ministre dans son rapport
annuel publié la semaine dernière le
défenseur des droits met en garde l'état
contre le risque de rupture entre les
services publics et les usagers en 2018
94 % des réclamations qui ont été
adressées portait en effet sur cette
relation des usagers avec les services
publics
parmi les premiers sujets de
préoccupation figurent la
dématérialisation des procédures
administratives que le gouvernement
souhaite achever en 2022
d'une part cette dématérialisation
soulève de nombreuses difficultés
d'ordre technique et organisationnel il
n'ya qu'à se pencher sur la délivrance
des titres sécurisés dans les transports
pour voir que les exemples de
défaillances sont nombreux d'autre part
comme l'a très justement rappelé mon
collègue jean yves roux en janvier la
dématérialisation des services publics
nécessite une large couverture internet
un bon équipement des ménages et une
maîtrise de l'outil informatique
or plusieurs centaines de communes n'ont
toujours pas accès internet et 13
millions de français sont encore en
difficulté avec le numérique
sans compter le coût d'équipement
informatique que l'on fait bien sûr
peser sur les ménages
le numérique est un facilitateur
indéniable dans de nombreux domaines
il n'est pas question de remettre en
cause un tel progrès mais dans cette
phase de transition
il est essentiel de renforcer
l'accompagnement et l'inclusion
numérique car une absence de l'état dans
les territoires peu amplifié les
difficultés d'accès au droit est le
sentiment d'injustice et d'abandon
notamment en zone rurale où les services
de proximité sont en déshérence
il existe une fracture territoriale de
plus en plus profonde entre la france
des métropoles et la france des
territoires qui cumule toutes les
difficultés déserts médicaux suppression
de services dans les hôpitaux la justice
fermetures d'écoles et de commerces
hausse du coût de la vie et des
transports en commun est inexistant
ajoutez à cela la disparition des
services publics et vous obtenez un
terreau fertile pour les extrêmes
aussi madame la ministre je souhaite
savoir quelles sont les actions que le
gouvernement va mettre en oeuvre
pour reconnecter les territoires et
rendre effective la promesse
républicaine d'égalité d'accès au droit
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires des relations
avec les collectivités territoriales
madame jacqueline gourault donner la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur eric gold
vous avez raison je partage votre
diagnostic si la dématérialisation de
certains services est indispensable pour
répondre aux besoins de nos concitoyens
nous devons être très attentifs aussi à
la situation des 13 millions de
personnes qui ressentent des difficultés
dans l'usagé du numérique
pour cela le gouvernement agit dans
trois directions d'abord pour renforcer
la présence du numérique sur le
territoire avec un engagement de plus de
3 milliards du gouvernement aidé en cela
par les collectivités territoriales qui
agissent aussi sur les territoires pour
développer l'accès au très haut débit
d'ici 2022
je ne parle pas aussi du réseau mobile
qui grâce à l'accord historique que
julien de normandie a passé avec eux
permet un très bon développement
territorial mais il faut accompagner et
la mise en place de mesures fortes
d'inclusion numérique tente avec le
guichet cohésion numérique des
territoires qui se traduit par un
soutien financier jusqu'à 150 euros pour
l'installation d'équipements et puis il
ya également le pass numérique qui
permet d'accéder en compétences avec des
personnes qui sont qui ont besoin d'être
formés qui sont les moins à l'aise avec
le numérique et enfin troisièmement avec
un accompagnement humain nécessaire de
nos concitoyens qui sont très éloignées
si je fais dire du numérique au milieu
je dirais ou à l'intérieur des maisons
notamment de service public
il y en a mille quatre cent sur le
territoire et il y à aussi la présence
dans les sous-préfectures et dans les
préfectures de médiateur numérique pour
aider
les usagers vous pouvez être assuré
monsieur le sénateur de la détermination
du gouvernement à améliorer bien sûr la
présence numérique sur le territoire
mais aussi accompagner donc la mise en
oeuvre de l'accompagnement des personnes
qui sont loin du numérique
merci claude hamelin ministre ' je vais
donner la parole de notre collègue
monique lubin pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
ma question s'adresse et initialement à
monsieur le premier ministre
depuis quelques jours nous assistons à
une véritable cacophonie émanant de
votre gouvernement sur fond de réforme
des retraites alors que la concertation
sur cette réforme touche à sa fin alors
que depuis le début il a toujours été
établi que le recul de l'âge de la
retraite n'était pas à l'ordre du jour
voilà que vos ministres jouent des
partitions bien différente
c'est tout d'abord madame la ministre
des solidarités qui ouvre le débat en
affirmant que le sujet n'est pas tabou
sensu de manière fort légitime
l'étonnement du haut-commissaire pour
qui cette question ne faisait pas partie
du cahier des charges si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi
après un rétropédalage de madame la
ministre des solidarités c'est au tour
du porte parole du gouvernement de
réaffirmer que le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite faisait partie
intégrante de la concertation mais
finalement s'agit-il d'une cacophonie ou
bien d'un jeu de rôles savamment
orchestré monsieur le premier ministre a
affirmé affirmé hier qu'il ne
reviendrait pas sur l'âge de départ à la
retraite tout en précisant qu'il
faudrait néanmoins s'interroger sur un
allongement de la durée du travail
propos repris peu ou prou ce matin même
par le haut commissaire tout cela n'est
que confusion
ma question est donc simple existe-t-il
dans votre gouvernement une volonté
clairement établie et partager de
maintenir ce droit à nos yeux non
négociable notamment pour ceux qui sont
entrés tôt dans le monde du travail
et qui exercent le plus souvent des
métiers pénibles droit qui devra être
assorti bien évidemment d'un niveau de
pension suffisant pour vous répondre je
donne la parole je signale simplement
corps soit mort à l'initiative de la
commission des affaires sociales un
débat avec entre les partenaires sociaux
et le haut commissaire se déroule dans
notre salle clemenceau monsieur le
ministre auprès du premier ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
monsieur fesneau pour vous répondre
merci monsieur le président mais merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
[Musique]
cette question me permets de rappeler
les propos tenus
mais
j'aimerais pouvoir répondre à votre
collègue si ça ne vous dérange pas cette
question me permets de rappeler cette
personne question madame la sénatrice me
permets de rappeler les propos tenus par
le premier ministre hier devant
l'assemblée nationale à l'issue du
conseil des ministres
l'objectif de la réforme des retraites
c'est construire l'objectif de
l'abstrait s'il vous plaît l'objectif de
la réforme de retraites c'est de
construire un système de retraites plus
lisible plus juste plus solidaire dans
lequel un euro cote ici vous n'écoutez
pas c'est votre choix mais je pense que
d'autres peuvent être intéressés par la
réponse le sénateur donne les mêmes
droits à tous c'est le mandat qui a été
confié à jean paul delevoye
comme l'a rappelé le premier ministre
hier ce mandat n'a pas changé et ne
porte pas sur la question paramétrique
de l'âge minimal de départ à la retraite
dans le même temps regardons les faits
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie est
une réalité que nous devons regarder en
face il ya un million cinq de personnes
de plus de 85 ans aujourd'hui elles
seront cinq millions en 2050
on parle d'un changement démographique
comme il y en a peu dans l'histoire des
sociétés
le vieillissement la population qu'il
induit représente un défi majeur pour
notre protection sociale et son
financement notamment pour notre système
de santé de prise en charge des
personnes âgées dépendantes
il va demander des déployer des moyens
financiers considérables pour le feu la
prise en charge de la dépendance
bc le reste à charge des familles
améliorer les conditions de travail dans
les ehpad mieux prendre en compte la
charge à domicile céder ce motif que
nous pouvons partager et pour financer
ses besoins de vos nous n'augmenterons
pas les impôts
la question de la prise en compte de
l'espérance de vie est un paramètre
majeur de la pérennité de notre système
de protection sociale
cette question a été ouverte dans le
cadre du grand débat national et elle
n'est pas fermée madame la sénatrice il
le semble qu'il ne faut pas trancher
cette question avant de l'avoir posée au
plus bas donc les choses me paraissent
décidément clair nous sommes toujours
dans la confusion
nous ne pourrons pas faire payer la
solidarité pour la dépendance par les
gens qui travaillent longtemps sur des
métiers pénibles et qui commence très
tôt ça ne sera pas possible
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue christine bonfanti-dossat pour
le groupe l'est républicain vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresser au premier ministre
[Musique]
on répare et aurait donc pu éviter
aurait-on pu éviter les scènes de
violence les scènes de pillage commises
par les casseurs ce samedi lors du 18e
acte de mobilisation des gilet jaune
y at-il eu des défaillances et un manque
d'anticipation
faut-il appeler cela de l'amateurisme
toutes ces questions les français se les
posent ils ne veulent plus débattre ils
ne veulent plus de discours plus de
formules médiatique
ils veulent des actes nous ne sommes
plus dans le cadre d'un maintien de
l'ordre classique à la suite des
événements du 1er octobre à l'arc de
triomphe nous attendions déjà de votre
part des actes forts
or vous n'avez rien fait de plus et ne
rien faire de plus c'est laisser faire
aujourd'hui aucune mesure aux politiques
ne pourra apaiser durablement la
situation ce n'est pas vos incantations
qui calmeront le pays encore au moins le
recours à l'armée
monsieur le ministre votre en même temps
dans le domaine régalien est un
véritable échec
il faut adopter la scène politique qui
vaille celle de la fermeté la hauteur de
la violence celle que le sénat vous
propose depuis le mois de juin
alors monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
me dire à combien se chiffrent les
dégâts qui va les payer
les français qui verront leurs
cotisations d'assurance augmentent et où
êtes-vous infâme près de faire payer les
casseurs et puis je vous rappelle ma
question s'adresser au premier ministre
êtes vous sûr
[Musique]
êtes vous sûr êtes vous sûr qu'avec un
tel discrédit
le ministre de l'intérieur est encore à
mesure de poursuivre sa mission
place beauvau merci la parole au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur
messieurs le ronin elle avait la parole
monsieur le ministre
allez dis monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice christine bonfanti je suis de
remarques par rapport à votre question
d'abord je suis très heureux de
constater que maintenant vous nous
expliquer que ce à quoi nous avons à
faire face depuis le 17 novembre
ça n'est pas du maintien de l'ordre
classique ça n'est pas toujours ce qui a
été dit sur ces bancs je vous le
rappelle depuis le début nous disons de
ce mouvement il étant empreint d'une
très grande violence
une remise en cause de nos institutions
nous avons souvent parlé sédition je
suis heureux que depuis quelques
semaines seulement vous nous rejoignez
sur cette thématique
quelques semaines seulement mais nous
n'avons pas attendu que vous évoluez
dans l'analyse des faits et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que nous sommes ici
que nous gérons nous ce problème c'est
ce que les français souhaitaient tous
soyons là en gestion d après le premier
descend d après le 1er décembre
nous avons fait évoluer la doctrine nous
avons fait évoluer cette doctrine nous
n'avons pas rien fait les organisations
syndicales que nous voyons régulièrement
avec christophe castaner nous ont
remerciés de cette évolution doctrine
ils nous ont remerciés de cette latitude
qui leur a été laissé dans
l'interpellation dans la possibilité
d'agir
dix mille personnes interpellées 1800
personnes placées qui ont été jugés 40%
de peines de prison ferme
comment osez vous dire que nous ne
faisons rien comment osez vous dire que
nous ne faisons rien et nous allons
continuer et nous serons présents ce
samedi à nouveau samedi dernier nos
instructions n'ont pas été appliquées et
c'est très grave
c'est un dysfonctionnement majeur et ce
sont les policiers eux mêmes qui se sont
adressés à nous pour se plaindre de ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas reçu les bonne
instruction
alors samedi nous continuerons à assurer
l'ordre républicain nous considérons
nous continuerons à protéger la
république parce que c'est ce que nous
faisons et je vous demande simplement
interrogez vous que feriez vous à notre
place que s'est il passé entre 2007 et
que s'est il passé entre 2012 et 2017
et il ya eu beaucoup d'incidents d'ordre
public il y a eu beaucoup d'incidents
d'ordre public et nous nous avons pris
des mesures à la fois législatives et
des mesures opérationnelles qui vise à y
mettre un terme
et dès demain d2d samedi tous les
attroupements qui surgiront qui
comporteront des casseurs seront comme
nous l'avons annoncé immédiatement
dispersés merci
merci
la parole est à notre collègue line
perreault pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur à
l'heure où les français sont indignés de
voir leur pays exemple d'autres victimes
oubliées de tous subissent les dommages
collatéraux de cette crise je veux
parler ici des familles des forces de
l'ordre de leurs épouses leurs époux de
leurs enfants
depuis le début de l'année on dénombre
24 suicides dont 19 au sein de la police
nationale des femmes et des hommes qui
s'étaient engagés pour protéger les
français depuis des mois la police
essaie de maintenir l'ordre dans des
manifestations chaque fois plus
violentes
les familles de ces derniers subissent
au quotidien via les réseaux sociaux une
agressivité telles qu'elles demandent à
leurs enfants de ne plus dire que leurs
parents et policiers aux gendarmes en
plus dans les cours d'école se rejoue
les scènes vues sur les écrans entre les
forces de l'ordre et les manifestants
comment expliquer dès lors un enfant
qu'il n'ait pas honte d'avoir un parent
qui a choisi cet engagement
l'association femmes des forces de
l'ordre en colère de ma région
bien avant les manifestations des gilets
jaunes avaient alerté le président de la
république sur les conditions de travail
de leurs époux ce dernier leur avait
répondu en août 2017 quelles seraient
reçus par le ministre de l'intérieur
or depuis le remaniement ministériel
rien n'a été mis en oeuvre pour entendre
leurs voix que comptez vous faire
monsieur le ministre pour protéger ces
familles pourriez vous en aurez les
promesses de notre président et prendre
le temps de recevoir et d'écouter ces
femmes
pour vous répondre car l'auteure
féministe de l'intérieur merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
je crois que c'est la deuxième question
à laquelle je réponds et je crois je le
rappelle a quelques-uns que nous avons
passé trois heures au sein de la
commission des lois a abordé le sujet
global de l'ordre public était un sujet
qui doit effectivement impliqués de
prendre le temps de l'action et puis il
y a les situations humaines vécu vous
avez abordé madame la sénatrice des
suicides
c'est un métier extrêmement difficile
avec des pressions fortes et c'est un
métier armée très régulièrement nous
avons effectivement des drames
épouvantables et je peux vous dire qu'il
n'ya pas eu une rencontre avec les
syndicats avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux avec les états
majors où je n'ai pas abordé la question
de la prévention du suicide dans cette
question nous la connaissons tous mais
elle est particulièrement forte
difficile inhumaines à traiter au sein
des effectifs de police comme de la
gendarmerie sur lesquels nous devons
être très mobilisés parce que ils
subissent cette violence du quotidien il
suivit cette mise en cause permanente
et puis il ya les familles et vous avez
raison d'aborder effectivement cela
sachez madame la sénatrice que nous
mettons en place de façon systématique
et la gendarmerie nationale est par
exemple un modèle qui est reproduit dans
beaucoup d'entreprises privées nous
mettons en place de façon systématique
1a commun ou psychologique médical et
social pour les proches
chaque fois qu'il y à des attaques ou
des drames nous mobilisons aussi des
moyens financiers pour sécuriser
sécuriser la vie le quotidien de nos
forces et en particulier de nos
gendarmes qui vivent vous le savez dans
des lieux regroupés il est évident que
nous devons aussi les protéger quand à
l'anonymat non pas pour que ce qu'il
pourrait faire soit caché mais tout
simplement pour que leur quotidien et
leurs interventions dans des procédures
judiciaires puis souffert se faire aussi
sous le couvert de l'anonymat est ce la
raison pour laquelle j'ai signé un
arrêté le 12 février dernier qui étend
la liste des services dont les agents ne
peuvent voir leur identité dévoilée
notamment dans les médias parce qu'il
faut protéger protéger tout le monde
enfin madame la sénatrice vous m'invitez
a rencontré une association que je ne
connais pas territoriale par contre je
peux vous dire que le dialogue avec les
organisations sociales et permanent à
17 heures je recevrai avec laurent nunez
la totalité des organisations syndicales
et je peux vous dire que depuis nous
cessons de le faire et que les
conditions de travail de nos gardiens de
la paix notamment à travers l'accord que
nous avons signé oman 9 au mois de
décembre sont fortement améliorés et
c'est nécessaire et juste merci madame
un apéro quelques secondes quelques
secondes simplement monsieur le ministre
vous nous avez dit cette semaine que
vous envisagez un plan de recrutement
dans la police alors changer l'image
négative que cette fonction inspire à
certains et redonner à ces femmes et ces
hommes engagés respect et dignité
merci à parler à d'autres collègues
arnaud devait mener pour le groupe de la
république en bas merci vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres collègues
j'aurais aimé poser une question premier
ministre pour le plaisir pour le plaisir
d'entendre pour la troisième fois son
nom scandé sur les bancs socialistes
c'est suffisamment rare et agréable de
d'entendre le premier ministre a clamé
sur les bancs socialistes néanmoins et
j'en suis très heureux ma question
s'adresse à et madame la ministre
emmanuelle wargon la jeunesse chers
collègues manifesté pour le climat
donnant aux générations qui la précède
est la nôtre en particulier une leçon de
sagesse et de clairvoyance au moment
même aux mets au même moment l'un 110e
déclaré à bord de l' eric l'america
grande et sous pavillon italien avec à
bord des milliers de fioul de propulsion
et des containers de manière de matières
dangereuses
l'europe nous accompagne avec notamment
l'intervention des bâtiments de sa
flotte pour intervenir de manière
curative sur la pollution est en lien
avec françoise cartron ma question porte
bien sûr sur les mesures prises en
réaction à la pollution pour protéger
nos côtes et nos zoo alors certes et
c'est l'occasion de le saluer depuis la
catastrophe de l'erika
l'union européenne a accru la sécurité
maritime par des mesures
et des règles de prévention d'adoption
des paquets et ricard 1 2 et 3 et l'
agence européenne sont des outils
efficaces
ainsi le grand d amérique avait fait
l'objet en 2010 d'un certain nombre de
contrôles qui avait relevé 35
déficiences techniques dont
quelques-unes 14 sur la sécurité
incendie
mais en octobre dernier à hambourg les
contrôles ne relevait plus que 3 défaut
de règlement dont l'un concernait la
rétention du fuel à bord alors les
principaux risques liés au transport
maritime sont endiguée grâce à l'europe
qui nous a protégés
néanmoins une partie du chemin reste à
faire alors madame la ministre
si l'amérique à grande et nous montre
qu'en ce domaine aussi
nous avons besoin d'europe nous avons
besoin de régulation
ma question porte simplement sur la
façon dont la france entend plaider pour
un renforcement de la réglementation
relative au transport maritime auprès de
nos partenaires
bien qu on vous répondra par les
collations quaker et corps auprès du
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire
madame la ministre monsieur président du
sénat madame messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur arnaud de belenet
vous l'avez dit le naufrage de grandes
baies america est une catastrophe
environnementale face à laquelle le
ministère de la transition écologique et
solidaire a réagi immédiatement
il s'agit d'un navire italien en
provenance de hambourg à destination de
casablanca qui a fait naufrage à 320 km
des côtes à 4500 mètres de profondeur le
ministre d'état françois de rugy s'est
rendu sur place dès jeudi dernier
poursuivre pour assurer heure par heure
le suivi de l'incident mettre en place
les opérations de secours pour saluer le
sauvetage des vingt-sept personnes à
bord et pour renforcer l'engagement
d'une lutte contre les incendies ainsi
que la sécurisation de la zone
vous l'avez rappelé une directive
européenne organise les contrôles et en
22 ans d'exploitation sous pavillon
italien
35 contrôle dans différents ports
européens ont été effectués sur ce
navire dont une fois à dunkerque en 2010
à chaque fois une autorisation a navigué
a été donné le dernier contrôle date du
26 octobre 2018 à hambourg en france
nous effectuons 1600 contrôle de ce type
bien sûr si l'anc est montré une erreur
manifeste il faudrait sévir nous en
sommes maintenant à contenir au maximum
cette catastrophe avec huit navires
actuellement sur zone et sept containers
c'est une mobilisation internationale
deux des navires ont été affrétés sous
l'égide de l'agencé européenne de
sécurité maritime
nous avons également un bateau espagnol
qui est là grâce à la coopération
bilatérale et des moyens mobilisés par
l'armateur nous suivons également la
pollution grâce à un système
satellitaire communautaire appelé klinsi
net une mise en demeure de l'armateur a
été fait pour mettre fin aux pollutions
par hydrocarbures par la pollution des
containers nous avons lancé une enquête
administrative judiciaire et technique
pour faire la lumière sur les
circonstances de l'accident et appeler
sa responsabilité
bien sûr en fonction des résultats de l'
enquête nous ferons les propositions
nécessaires au niveau européen pour
améliorer toujours plus la sécurité et
les réglementations
merci à parler monsieur philippe pouillé
pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues étant donnée la thématique de
la semaine ma question concerne la
francophonie mais en un préambule
j'aurais quand même vous dire que je
suis au relativement marquée par
l'absence volontaire du premier ministre
aujourd'hui dans nos rangs
voici un an sous la coupole de
l'institut de france le prendre là
public prononcé un discours relatifs à
la francophonie
après avoir partagé la conception de ce
qu'est aujourd'hui la francophonie c'est
à dire cette langue française devenue le
centre de toutes les nations et de tous
les peuples où elle fait souche dans sa
variété
le chef de l'état a fixé un cap
apprendre échanger et créer en français
outre ces engagements il s'est projeté
au-delà de nos frontières
il a souhaité que la france puisse à
travers son aide publique au
développement
réaffirmer son engagement fort pour
l'éducation à cet engagement en matière
de développement
le panda à public a également annoncé
des mesures concrètes notamment en
proposant un volontariat international
pour le français et un doublement des
missions du service civique sur cet
enjeu en annonçant un nouvel élan pour
les lycées français et un doublement du
nombre d'élèves inscrits dans le réseau
scolaire d'ici 2025 et en demandant à
nos établissements du supérieur de
s'implanter hors de nos frontières et de
se regrouper en campus
l'ambition est important qu il a
également ajouté de nouvelles missions
aux acteurs de l'audiovisuel francophone
et à nombre d'institutions qu'il faut
aujourd'hui partout dans le monde
vive la francophonie or à ce jour le
vantail internationale n'est toujours
pas mis en place les budgets alloués à
la fois aux alliances françaises au
lycée sont en diminution et
l'audiovisuel consacré la francophonie
est en plein doute
alors monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous dire un an après ce grand discours
quelles sont les actions du gouvernement
pour traduire les nombreux engagements
annoncés dont vous répandre la parole et
à monsieur jean baptiste lemoyne
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
rop des affaires étrangères vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur mouillé je salue
également le vice président délégué de
la section française de l'assemblée
parlementaire de la francophonie je le
signale parce que ce sont les parlements
qui ont été pionniers avant les
gouvernements et nous avons fêté
en 2017 les 50 ans de la pf alors un an
après le grand le discours fondateur
effectivement prononcé par le président
de la république sous la coupole de
l'institut de france
et bien c'est un foisonnement
d'initiatives et d'actions qui ont vu le
jour
parlons moyens budgétaires nous sommes
passés tout simplement de 97 millions
d'euros octroyée au soutien au système
éducatif dans les pays en développement
parce que nous avons besoin pour que le
français soit une réalité non pas
seulement une potentialité et bien que
nous puissions accompagner ces systèmes
éducatifs à un budget de 208 millions
d'euros en 2018 et nous allons la crotte
pour passer à 300 millions d'euros
par ailleurs il y à une synergie des
actions conduites aussi avec
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie le président la république
a pu évoquer ces sujets hier en
rencontrant la nouvelle secrétaire
générale madame louise mushikiwabo
et tout cela va se décliner au sein des
institutions européennes pour que le
français soit toujours plus et mieux
enseigner aux fonctionnaires
internationaux parce que il est
essentiel pour que l'europe soit une
réalité également que le multilinguisme
soit une réalité concrète et qu'on
puisse s'y exprimer en français
s'agissant des volontaires
internationaux une idée qui avait
d'ailleurs été mis sur la table par
joëlle garriaud-maylam nous en sommes au
stade de l'expérimentation mais nous
entendons bien passé au stade de
l'industrialisation si je puis dire
ainsi par ailleurs hier avec frédéric
vidal nous posions la première pierre
d'une maison des étudiants de la
francophonie au sein de la cité
internationale
elle va pouvoir accueillir 150 étudiants
francophones en 2020 et ça sera un lieu
naturellement d'inspiration et puis vous
l'avez dit les campus
le campus franco-sénégalais le campus
franco tunisien tous ces chantiers
avancent bien et je sais que c'est un
sujet qui rassemble largement
j'ai d'ailleurs une pensée pour jacques
legendre et michel andré qui ont porté
haut cette flamme et que nous nous
attachons à perpétuer en semblant tu
voyais
mais seul unissent j'entends la liste
des actions engagées
je reste en tous les cas le témoin sur
le terrain dans des caisses de réelle
entre les discours et les cotisations
alors nous attendrons les mois qui
viennent pour voir la traduction d'une
façon générale je pense que même sous la
coupole de l'institut de france
ils peuvent parfois avoir un discours
plus modestes mais des engagements
qu'ils soient tenus
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue jean françois husson pour le
groupe l'est républicain monsieur le
sénateur oui monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame emmanuelle
wargon ministre madame la ministre
samedi dernier dans le calme la bonne
humeur et une ambiance festive près de
quatre cent mille français dans une
univers une diversité d'âge de
conditions d'engagement associatif ou
politique ont manifesté pour que soit
revue à la hausse
l'ambition de la france en matière
d'écologie au lendemain de la grève de
la jeunesse pour le climat fustigeant
dans les deux cas l'inaction du
gouvernement
je note que cela vous a laissé sans voix
et sans réaction quand lierre nicolas
hulot claqué la porte en regrettant la
politique des petits pas autrement dit
l'immobilisme
madame la ministre les français vous
exhorte à agir aujourd'hui
pouvez vous donc nous dire quelle est
l'ambition du gouvernement sur votre
politique en faveur du climat et la
promotion d'une écologie positive plutôt
que punitive pour vous répondre là
parler madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès de huit la transition écologique
et solidaire ministre monsieur le
président du sénat mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur russe on vous avait
cité la mobilisation des jeunes et la
mobilisation de nos concitoyens pour le
climat vous avez bien fait parce que ces
mobilisations sont salutaires et elles
sont importantes
nous avons besoin d'une prise de
conscience nous avons besoin d'une
volonté commune pour agir et pousser au
maximum la transformation écologique et
solidaire dont notre pays a besoin et
dont d'ailleurs le monde entier a besoin
ces marches sont importantes de même que
les débats qui ont eu lieu et je pense
aux débats qui ont eu lieu avec le
président de la république à gréoux les
bains avec de nombreux jeunes qui ont
été également interpellé le président
alain
tiens et demain nous rencontrerons avec
jean michel blanquer françois de rugy
brune poirson et gabriela talent des
lycéens qui ont participé aussi à des
débats dans leur établissement
il ne s'agit pas d'être interpellé les
uns contre les autres il ne s'agit pas
d'être opposés les uns aux autres il
s'agit ensemble d'agir pour cette
transformation écologique au ministère
de la transition écologique nous sommes
à la tâche tous les jours nous n'avons
pas attendu ces mobilisations pour agir
nous sommes déterminés nous avançons en
matière énergétique
laprise la bonne programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie a été
présenté récemment en 2020 fermeront les
deux premiers réacteurs nucléaires en
france
à fessenheim nous avons signé le projet
de territoire d'ici 2022 fermeront les
quatre centrales à charbon qui reste en
métropole cette transition et est en
cours elle est faite avec les
territoires que nous accompagnons nous
créons l'office français de la
biodiversité en matière de biodiversité
nous mettons en place ce onzième parc
naturel nous partageons mieux la
ressource en eau à travers les assises
de l'eau nous sommes à la tâche tous les
jours et sur l'économie circulaire nous
avons présenté une feuille de route de
l'économie circulaire qui va également
nous permettre d'être ambitieux en la
matière et cette feuille de route
arrivera prochainement devant
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat le
président de la république l'a dit à gré
où il faut aller plus vite plus loin
plus fort
ce sera aussi l'enjeu de la sortie du
grand débat que de proposer une feuille
de route complémentaire pour être au
rendez-vous de la transition écologique
et solidaire
merci la ministre réponse convenue
madame la ministre je le dis très
simplement le gouvernement reste petit
bras un moment où en fait vous avez
affaire un dossier pour le moins
préoccupant et il ne faut surtout pas
geler les ambitions en plein
réchauffement climatique je vous donner
quelques exemples la ppe
maintes fois repoussé dont on peine à
voir une ligne directrice la trajectoire
carbone pour le moins indécise le
développement des énergies alternatives
balbutiant la sortie du nucléaire aussi
peu sereine que le dossier de fermeture
des centrales à charbon depuis la
fiscalité verte mais sous le tapis
depuis la crise ils gilet jaune et qui
risque de demeurer longtemps à maquis où
se cachent mécontentement injustice et
colère
madame la ministre une action écologique
c'est aussi 100 milliards par an
consacrés au traitement de la pollution
de l'air la facture énergétique ces 40
milliards de déficit c'est à dire deux
tiers du déficit du commerce extérieur
alors faites confiance à vos partenaires
les collectivités territoriales
auxquelles je vous offre une belle
occasion de proposer sans délai une
nouvelle grande oie pacte 2 un plan
d'action pour le climat est la
transition écologique
madame la ministre il est temps d'agir
ou jupiter rist de risque de devenir et
hall le dieu du vent merci le procès les
questions d'actualité auront lieu le
mardi 26 mars à 16h45
je vais suspendre la séance se sera
reprise à 16h20 pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi d'orientation
des mobilités séance est suspendue
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement et on peut dire
que la guerre institutionnel est
déclarée entre le gouvernement et le
sénat puisque le premier ministre
edouard philippe a volontairement
boycotté cette séance de questions
d'actualité du sénat à cause de la
décision ce matin du bureau du sénat de
signaler à la justice le cas du
directeur de cabinet des manuels macron
patrick strzoda suspectés de faux
témoignage devant la commission d'
enquête sur la sphère benalla est
également de transmettre les
déclarations des deux hauts
fonctionnaires de l'elysée alexis colère
et le général lavernhe edouard philippe
qui a appelé le président du sénat
gérard larcher pour justifier son
boycott
et cette absence elle est très mal
passée auprès des sénateurs cet après
midi qui ont copieusement hué tous les
ministres qui sont venus répondre à
leurs questions les sénateurs
socialistes ont même tapé du poing sur
leur table en criant il est où il est où
à propos du premier ministre qui était
absent c'est dire si l'ambiance était
électrique cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle alors qu'on a appris au même
moment que le président de l'assemblée
nationale à richard ferrand avait annulé
sa participation demain à une conférence
devant les étudiants de sciences po
lille qu'il devait animer avec le
président du sénat gérard larcher une
conférence sur la démocratie
parlementaire
un boycott aux mêmes motifs de la
décision du bureau du sénat
dans la sphère benalla on peut donc dire
que cette affaire benalla a réduit à
néant les relations entre d'un côté le
gouvernement et l'assemblée et de
l'autre le sénat merci beaucoup
alexandre pour toutes vos précisions et
on continue à les réactions justement et
vous au thème traduit avec le ministre
des relations avec le parlement à marc
fesneau cette boutade oui marc fesneau
et bien à votre réaction tout d'abord à
ce boycott des questions d'actualité par
le premier ministre et doit flipper
également l'annulation du déplacement en
commun que devait avoir lieu entre
gérard à l'archet et richard ferrand
demain à lille j'ai pas de réaction
particulière va avoir le premier
ministre a appelé le président larcher
pour lui donner les motifs de son
absence s'est défait normaux dans la vie
parlementaire on va pas non plus et du
corps et les choses par ailleurs les
charges pas bien
rien que ça c'est très bien mais je
pense que c'est bien qu'ils aient un
dialogue direct entre le premier
ministre et le président de l'assemblée
nationale ou du sénat pour expliquer ce
que sont les faits est-ce que ce qu'ils
peuvent être des déclarations ou des
décisions qui peuvent poser question en
tout cas à l'exécutif au à d'autres la
deuxième chose que je voulais dire quand
même au passage chez moi je suis un
ministre des relations avec le parlement
qui par fonction mais aussi par
construction et conviction croit
vraiment à l'utilité du bicamérisme et
donc vous ne trouverez pas à remettre en
cause le sénat dans sa fonction et dans
son utilité le bureau après une décision
j'en prends acte
reconnaissons aussi en tout cas beaucoup
d'observateurs le dise que c'était une
décision de nature politique
il faut simplement que le sénat
l'assument comme une décision politique
d'ailleurs elle est intéressante à
double titre cet intérêt un procès
politique
en tout cas je n'ai juste c'est une
décision sur fondement politique
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de voir qui
a voté cette décision manifestement les
républicains le parti socialiste qui
dans une collusion intéressantes du
moment a fait qu'ils ont pris cette
décision mais pour le reste je voudrais
dire deux choses
moi je me réfère à ce qu'a dit le
président marseille qui est membre de la
majorité qui est un membre influent et
solide de la majorité qui a dit cette
décision elle est superfétatoire elle
est fragile elle est injustifiée ça me
parait détails sur les âmes en clair oui
mais les membres de la majorité donc il
est moins suspect par construction
d'être comment dirais-je influencé par
tel ou tel il a dit des choses très
clair je pense qu'ils avaient marseille
parle de raison et puis dernier point on
est dans un moment où je pense que les
français ont besoin que les assemblées
fonctionne que les assemblées
fonctionnant sans mais je suis pas sûr
que ce genre les s'interroge jusque là
décidant à abaisser par le moment mais
je suis pas sûr que ce type de décision
que ce genre de procès politique qui
peuvent être intentées à tel ou tel
permettent d'aider rehausser le niveau
du débat public et le débat politique et
je suis sûr que la raison va revenir ce
que cette maison que je connais bien est
une maison qui normalement travail avec
raison et dans la volonté de l'intérêt
collectif je crois que les français nous
attendent sur l'intérieur est chargé mal
parti n'a pas réussi le lésé par richard
perron dont je vous parle non gens qui
nous avaient très mal mer sur mon propos
je vous dis que dans un moment comme ça
on n'a pas besoin de décisions qui
sautent d'édition qui manifestement
sondés sur des fondements politiques ça
ne concerne pas richard ferrand ça
concerne plutôt la décision du bureau ce
matin
d'accord merci beaucoup marqué nous
d'avoir répondu à mes questions merci à
vous pour cette réaction et françoise
laborde argent sur ce plateau bonsoir
c'est un trait de la haute garonne
bien que cette absence du premier
ministre mesures de rétorsion on voit du
bureau du sénat
ce matin fait beaucoup réagir vous le
regrettez alors oui je vais dire que je
le regrette parce que bon j'ai entendu
les propos de marc fesneau en disant que
peut-être le sénat ne sort pas grandie
mais dans ces cas là moi je dis que mort
si le premier ministre n'est pas là non
plus je pourrais dire aussi que le
gouvernement ne sort pas grandie donc ça
c'est de la politique politicienne comme
je n'aime pas après sur le choix du
bureau
il est exact moi je n'ai pas participé
puisque je n'étais pas membre de cette
commission spéciale donc je suis allé à
quelques auditions comme tout le monde
sur le choix final je pense que l'on
peut comprendre l'aspect parce qu'on ne
ment pas à une commission denquête donc
les deux personnes messieurs bennane à
écrase soit disons un peu plus mis en
avant est peut-être cette déclaration à
la justice ne me choque pas pour le
reste c'est une suspicion de faux
témoignages et voilà je mets des points
de suspension je ne suis pas membre du
bureau
donc je vois en effet ce que dit marc
raynaud ce que disent d'autres personnes
c'est peut-être une façon aussi de se
dire qu'on n'a pas choisi le bon moment
mais on ne choisit jamais le moment de
la fin d'une commission denquête ça
tombe mal avec les réformes
constitutionnelles qui arrive et ce
serait dommage qu'il y ait une guerre
alors que le bicamérisme est tellement
important voilà donc les choses bon
voilà une question une sérié une séance
de questions d'actualité un peu houleuse
j'ose espérer que chacun retrouvera ses
esprits et remettra au niveau car
richard vachon et qu'il devait se rendre
demande devant les étudiants de sciences
po à lille avec le président du sénat
gérard larcher a lui aussi lieu décidé
bien d'annuler de boycotter à cette
conférence il dit on ne peut pas d'un
côté abc me par le moins vouloir le
promouvoir au
la commission denquête n'était pas à
l'assemblée bien sûr puisqu'elle est à
majorité la république en marche je
pense qu'il y aurait eu notre époque
voilà je crois qu'il ne faut pas non
plus dire bon nous on n'aurait pas fait
comme ça chacun reste chez soi avant le
président inférant il y a eu quelques
soucis à l'assemblée sont prêtés par son
prédécesseur mais du temps d'avant
j'aime bien aller à barcelone
voilà entre monsieur bartolone et
monsieur larcher n'étaient pas tous les
jours facile non plus donc je pense que
justement si on veut respecter le
bicamérisme et continuer à construire
il va falloir que la vapeur pro tombe
et puis qu'on recommence à travailler
alors on continue à bien cette émission
et on repasse par la salle à des
conférences où nous attend sera nuit
avec un des coûts rapporteur de cette
commission d'enquêté parlementaire le
socialiste jean-pierre sueur jean-pierre
sur votre réaction au boycott d'edouard
philippe de la séance de questions
d'actualité bien sûr lié à la décision
du bureau du sénat de ce matin également
richard ferrand qui annule son
déplacement commun qui était prévue
demain avec gérard larcher si c'est un
boycott de la part du premier ministre
c'est incompréhensible et le fait que le
président de l'assemblée nationale
renonce à rencontrer gérard larcher est
tout à fait incompréhensible
le président de l'assemblée nationale
devrait défendre le contrôle
parlementaire
qu'est ce que nous avons fait nous avons
fait un rapport
c'est pas de la faute au sénat si
monsieur benalla s'est comporté comme il
s'y conformer ce n'est pas de la faute
sénat s'il y a eu tous les
dysfonctionnements induits et si on les
a laissés faire
c'est pas la faute au sénat si de hauts
personnages ont menti devant une
commission d enquête parlementaire
exécuteront jours oui mais aujourd'hui
nous tirons les conséquences de cela
conformément à la constitution
et puisque monsieur le premier ministre
parle tellement de la séparation des
pouvoirs
il devrait être très respectueux de la
séparation des pouvoirs
nous parlementaires nous faisons notre
travail tel qu'il est prévu dans la
constitution
les chats errants qui parlent de femmes
politiciennes dans la saison il abaisse
le parlement qui a bercé par le tout à
fait tort puisque moi je n'ai pas fait
ce travail en tant que membre d'un parti
politique mais en tant que parlementaire
chargée avec mes collègues par la
constitution de contrôler le pouvoir
exécutif est d'évaluer les politiques
publiques points est ce que c'est une
crise politique ouverte pour vous une ça
fait longtemps qu'on avait pas d ouvre
une crise politicienne c'est leur
problème
moi je dis que dans cette affaire nous
nous intéressons à la vérité aux droits
et à la loi merci merci jean grâce à
pour votre réaction
merci beaucoup autant pour 7 à nouvelle
réaction est ce que vous remontez
françoise laborde et bien qu'il y ait
des conséquences sur la révision des
institutions le sénat qui a pu me
braquer à l'elysée par ce vote du bureau
qui pourrait en faire les frais à lors
de la prochaine révision
constitutionnelle c'est un souci quelque
bien sûr c'est ce que je vous ai dit je
pense que cela ne pouvait pas plus mal
tomber
mais je crois aussi en l'intelligence
des uns et des autres parce que les
modifications constitutionnelles des
institutions ne se font pas pour un jour
pour deux jours où après une crise c'est
quand même quelque chose qui va engager
notre pays pour des années il ya des
choses qui étaient déjà engagés
certaines ont été arrêtés du fait du
grand débat parce qu'on
les savoirs aussi un petit peu ce qui
allait se dire sur nos territoires
donc moi je crois quand même ont
l'intelligence personnelle de chaque
individu qui va participer à ces
réformes institutionnelles ça pourrait
avoir un impact sur la question de la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires ça
pourrait faire l'objet d'âpres
négociations à présent entre emmanuel
macron les gens à marcher ça peut ça peu
puisqu'en c'est que il y avait eu des
avancées sur les territoires garder un
certain nombre de sénateurs ou de député
dans les territoires ruraux pour que
justement il ne se retrouve pas
complètement déshabillés on le dit au
niveau du sénat certains disent que le
sénat est trop représentés au niveau du
rural
bon vous savez bien que les textes de
loi sont quand même fait autour des
urbains il faut lui dire
après bien sûr on pense à nos
territoires donc c'est quand même le
rôle des sénateurs et nous avons quand
même aussi tous les territoires
outre-mer
parce que quand on vote une loi c'est
pour tous ce n'est pas seulement pour la
métropole et je dirais plutôt urbaine
donc j'espère voilà que les uns et les
autres vont se dire nous travaillons
pour notre pays ce n'est pas facile
aujourd'hui je vais vous le dire avec
tout ce qui se passe donc il faut garder
la tête froide et j'espère que chacun
après quelques jours de folie et
peut-être sénat était pourtant dans son
rôle avec cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire
c'est ce que je vous ai dit pour moi la
commission denquête c'est quelque chose
d'important
vous le savez on jure chaque fois de
dire la vérité toute la vérité j'ai mené
une commission denquête donc je sais ce
que c'est c'est pour ça que par rapport
aux 2
je pense qu'il ne fallait surtout pas
laisser passer
on craint alexandra merci j'ai senti que
c'était un peu plus compliqué pour les
trois autres personnes
pourquoi on a gardé monsieur strzoda
pourquoi on n'a pas gardé les autres
c'est vrai que la justice va faire son
travail donc un moment le sénat va se
retirer et la querelle et où vous la
montée un peu
de colère où va s'arrêter puisque la
justice va faire son travail
bien sûr ce n'était jamais arrivé ou
alors il faut je sais pas il faut
remonter je crois que c'était jamais
arrivé donc une commission denquête si
on veut que la commission denquête garde
son rôle de contrôle dans le cadre du
bicamérisme ce que je vous dis on pourra
en reparler peut-être dans quelques
temps quand l'assemblée aura une
commission denquête affaire on peut pas
exiger des gens donc nous auditionnons
d'avoir une honnêteté totale puisque il
jure devant le président et les membres
de la commission et d'un autre côté dire
non mais c'est pas grave
donc ça s'est trouvée alors après qu'ils
aient de la surenchère
je ne ferai pas de commentaire vous me
connaissez
on va continuer cet entretien on repasse
par la salle des conférences pour une
nouvelle réaction
avec gérard longuet sénateur
oui gérard longuet votre réaction au
fait que l'on ait appris qu' edouard
philippe a donc boycotté la séance de
questions d'actualité au sénat également
que richard ferrand annuler demain son
déplacement commun qui était prévu avec
gérard larcher tout cela en réaction à
la décision qui a été prise par le
bureau du sénat
ce sont des gamineries qui ne sont pas à
la hauteur de la responsabilité de ses
hommes le premier ministre le président
de l'assemblée nous avons une
constitution de 58 qui fait du parlement
assemblée nationale et sénat des
pouvoirs autonome nous ne sommes pas
nous le sénateur les employés de
l'exécutif
qu'on soit de gauche contre la droite
nous sommes dans notre fonction de
contrôler le gouvernement
alors c'est pas toujours agréable d'être
contrôlé il se trouve que
malheureusement il ya une suspicion de
faux témoignages qui ne veut pas dire
d'ailleurs une certitude de faux
témoignages savions décidera loeb et
l'obligation le bureau du sénat avait
l'obligation comme le l'ancien article
40 du code de procédure pénale de
transmettre au parquet pour qu'il
examine et on verra bien ce que le
parquet dira richard ferrand qui dans un
communiqué juge que cela a été fait à
des fins politiciennes qui abaisse le
parlement il ne mâche pas ses mots le
présente à son âme il est parfaitement
hors de son
de son rôle il devrait au contraire se
réjouir de l'indépendance du parlement
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif
je respecte l'exécutif mais l'exécutif
doit respecter lui aussi les lois et
nous sommes là parlementaires députés et
sénateurs y sont que les députés sont
traditionnellement d'un camp ou d'un
autre
peut-être moins libre et moins
disponibles pour contrôler et nous nous
sommes libres nous sommes des sénateurs
nous ne devons pas notre élections à
l'exécutif
et nous disons très clairement qu'il y à
une suspicion de d'infraction pas de
violation de la déclaration sous serment
c'est un procès politique dont l'issue
était déjà écrite d'avancé dit la
république en marche le snat en
déconnexion les mots sont très durs du
côté bien sûr la majorité présidentielle
je crois que cette commission des lois
qui a été publique et dont les qui a été
très écouté par nos compatriotes montre
que le président de la commission des
lois philippe bas s'est comporté avec
beaucoup de mesure avec jean pierre
sueur ils sont posés l'un et l'autre des
questions extrêmement précise
naturellement muriel et ciblée tout
l'erreur c'est que l'exécutif manque
d'expérience politique est à oublier
simplement que l'assemblée comme le
sénat sont des organes indépendants
voulue par le peuple pour contrôler
l'exécutif
en tout cas les faits c'est que là on
est dans une crise politique n'est pas
une crise est au contraire moi je trouve
ça très bon je trouve que c'est un
rappel à l'ordre
chacun doit faire son métier et
l'exécutif doit respecter le législatif
ce qu'ils avaient tendance à oublier et
ce n'est pas le premier à l'oublier mais
la révision constitutionnelle n'a jamais
était bien engagée mais là c'est pire
que tout dans cette j'ai presque envie
de dire on revient aux fondamentaux at
on le droit de contrôler y compris des
choses désagréables à la réponse est oui
moi j'ai commencé jeune parlementaire à
partie ces êtres rapporteur d'une
commission denquête pour renvoyer
tenez vous bien en cour de justice le
ministre d'état ministre de l'intérieur
et bien j'ai fait ce travail avec mes
collègues de gauche et de droite
ce travail d enquête en toute liberté on
n'a jamais
considéré que c'était une crise c'est
simplement le fonctionnement des
institutions
personne dans notre pays n'est à l'abri
d'un contrôle et l'exécutif pas plus
merci beaucoup gérard longuet d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
merci à vous le porte parole du
gouvernement
benjamin griveaux a également réagi à
l'issue de cette séance de questions
d'actualité notamment sur l'absence et
c'est assez inédit au parlement lors
d'une séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement du premier ministre et
d'art philippe écoutez nous on a un
immense respect pour l'institution
sénatoriale qui si j'en crois les voix
qui s'élèvent y compris sur les bancs du
sénat s'est abîmé dans cette affaire
plutôt qu'elle ne s'est renforcé et donc
voilà s'il ya des décisions politiques
et que le sénat a fait de
au fond cette affaire une
instrumentalisation politique et nous on
est trop regardants est trop attachée à
l'institution sénatoriales pour ne pas
marquer aussi notre désaccord lens qui
est un désaccord et on peut considérer
que raisonnablement il ya assez peu de
respect dans la décision qui a été
rendue par le bureau du sénat et dont je
le redis beaucoup de sénateurs
s'émeuvent de la décision qui a été
prise
vous y voyez vous une lecture politique
françoise laborde à ce que le sénat
finalement instrumentalisés cette
commission denquête à cette saisine de
la justice ce matin pour atteindre le
chef de l'état alors ça je ne le dirai
pas parce que n'étant pas membre du
bureau et n'ayant pas participé à tout
le travail de fond parce que je sais que
valérie létard a fait quand même un gros
travail sur ce sujet puisque c'était la
vice-présidente chargée de présenter un
certain nombre d'arguments bond est sûre
j'ai lu le rapport comme beaucoup de
personnes parce que c'était quand même
intéressant alors ce qui est peut-être
politique c'est que l'assemblée
nationale donc prennent partie alors
qu'ils sont oserais-je dire au même
niveau que nous quand on considère que
nous sommes dans le cas du législatif et
le gouvernement c'est l'exécutif donc à
ce niveau là peut-être qu'il y en ait
fait un choix difficile après que le
premier ministre ne soit pas venu
aujourd'hui c'est son problème c'est sa
responsabilité
je ne sais pas si c'est le président de
la république qui lui a dit
il était d'accord voilà il ya des choses
on ne peut pas créer des événements
politiques quand on ne sait pas vraiment
le plus grave disait bruno retailleau ce
serait que cela donne un pousse à penser
par donc on fait payer les lampistes et
qu on exonère les autres ont six blancs
d'un côté et bien deux poids deux
mesures pour vincent kraz alexandre
benalla et les collaborateurs proches de
l'elysée alors je n'ai entendu bon je
suis pas sûr que les deux premiers donc
messieurs benalla iqra soit des
lampistes et c'est quand même un peu
voilà je pense qu'ils ont des niveaux
quand on voit l'importance je dirais de
monsieur b nana je ne les jamais
considéré comme un lampiste
donc bon mais je vous dis bon qu'il ait
dit cela c'était justement peut-être
pour justifier le choix qu au départ lui
il voulait que les cinq soit donc après
la dénie vos différents puisqu'elle
parquet apparemment c'est un peu plus
compliqué que cela
moi je ne considère pas je trouve ce
sont des jugements alors je veux pas
dire des jugements de valeur mais là
aussi quoi sont des mots il faut faire
attention aux mots que l'on utilise un
bresse avec nous et françoise laborde
puisque on évoquait justement valérie
létard qui a donc présenté ce matin son
rapport au bureau elle était au micro de
cannes tram il ya quelques instants un
outil
oui valérie létard pourriez-vous nous
dire exactement ce que vous avez
préconisé au sein de votre rapport et
bien tout d'abord rappelé que
conformément à ce que le président du
sénat souhaitées on a présenté un
rapport qui était posée en termes
juridiques en termes de droit en
rappelant point par point et on va dire
sujet après sujet demande après demande
sur quoi on se fonder juridiquement pour
saisir le ministère public et donc nous
avons essayé de présenter ce rapport
donc en droit suite à la lettre de
saisine du président bah qui présidait
la commission denquête et trois
catégories en fait on nous avons
distingué en trois niveaux la saisine en
tout cas la transmission ministère
public tout d'abord les personnes pour
lesquelles nous considérons que les
éléments qui permettent de fonder une
suspicion pour faux témoignages étaient
réunis établi mains sales draps dans le
sud oise
monsieur benalla et de monsieur strzoda
pour la partie nition démission de
monsieur pénale
on met vous mettez d'ailleurs patrick
strzoda au même niveau que vincent crasé
alexandre bédat la suspicion de faux
témoignages à qu'on met ces personnes au
même niveau c'est que nous on nous
interroge sur la grande question de
l'article 6 de leur donnant ce qui en
fait permet de caractériser en délit
toute personne qui fait un faux
témoignage alors qu'il a prêté serment
devant une commission denquête il s'agit
pas de la faire on juge pas la faire on
essaye de déterminer qui est suspect de
faux témoignages suspect une tranche ont
pas nous sommes pas le juge nous
transmet nature la cité thermale qui
décidera si oui ou non
donc les trois premiers ensuite nous
avons une deuxième catégorie où nous
avons instruit
effectivement selon les éléments qu'il
faut donner
conformément à la jurisprudence un
certain nombre d'éléments sont
identifiés mais ils ne sont pas
suffisants pour considérer qu'il ya une
suspicion de faux témoignages avéré à ce
stade c'est à dire que là aussi nous
transmettons à la justice sans
considérer qu'il ya suspicion de faux
témoignages avéré à ce stade nous n'en
avons pas tous les éléments
alexis kohler et lionel lavergne il
s'agit de monsieur colère de monsieur la
verte et monsieur strzoda pour les
autres éléments qui apparaissent dans le
rapport
et enfin et vous transmettez tout de
même nous transmettons mais nous
transmettant disons que tous les
éléments n'étaient pas réunis pour qu à
ce stade et que le bureau signal en fait
et saisissent la justice pour suspicion
de faux témoignages nous n'avions pas
nous considérons ne pas voir tous les
éléments et enfin nous transmettons
conformément à la lettre de philippe bas
les éléments qui sont figurer en annexe
du rapport et qui sont transmis à la
justice pour qu'elle puisse le cas
échéant pousser les investigations est
allé plus loin dans la procédure si
elles le jugent utile
voilà pour cette réaction de valérie
létard françoise laborde rapidement le
sénat a su faire preuve de son
indépendance dans cette affaire sera oui
là je suis obligé de dire oui bien sûr
on est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord
certaines vous avez vu bon de toute
façon il ya eu un vote ce matin et
toutes les voies n'ont pas été pour
mais là dessus on est d'accord c'est à
dire que l'indépendance du sénat il ya
une procédure on aboutit à un résultat
je pense que valérie létard a très bien
expliqué entre ce qui était suspicion de
faux témoignage faux témoignage peut
être vraiment avéré vend donc elle
explique très bien donc l'indépendance
du sénat est un total bien merci merci à
vous et françoise laborde d'avoir
participé à cette émission avant de se
quitter on veut tourner dans l'hémicycle
puisque et bien à l'absence du premier
ministre continue de faire parler les
sénateurs à part des rappels au
règlement alexandre ponsard
louis est finie puisque les sénateurs
devaient comment continuer à examiner la
loi sur les mobilités mais le sénateur
socialiste jean pierre sueur a fait un
rappel au règlement concernant ce
boycott du premier ministre au décès des
séances de questions d'actualité
concernant également la décision de
richard ferrand d'annuler sa visite à
sciences po lille avec gérard larcher il
a trouvé ces décisions inquiétante et il
a demandé au gouvernement de respecter
le contrôle du parlement qui est
garantie par la constitution
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
précisions c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi à 18h30 on
va plus loin présenté par rebecca
fitoussi très bonne sur des programmes
son public sénat
[Musique]
public sénat au coeur des territoires
c'est